[Music]
so
happy to be here benton and trixie
mattel
are here i'm a professional singer
i'm so happy to be here we're happy to
have you are we friends
yes when you listen i was just telling
about you listen to pods a lot you
believe you know the people so then when
you meet for their pod
it just feels like yeah yeah i've been
having an
unknowing three-way conversation with
you people yeah me trying to not ask you
if you found new liner and i don't know
i'm stopping yeah i'm like yes i did
thank you for asking no one asked about
my white eyeliner should we tell the
story about
what he's doing here should we tell the
story of us during drag race
oh yes you were there right i love
trixie we did celebrity drag race you
were on the episode right after us
we did it with miss alyssa there's her
mirror that's so fun
it was i was different look roo is my
friend i can say this
i think they were confused you know
their families so phoebe robinson our
friend was on there and you know how
you're supposed to bring like
people to like cheer you on uh-huh well
she brought us
but they credited her phoebe's friend
not her name or anything
i was just trying to be respectful and
not make it about me believe it or not
and i was like this is someone else's
show let me just not like
be like a whitney's hair like let me be
that person
and they went along with it they sure
did they're like why is she on the
runway they said they said
they blurred her they changed her voice
unsolved mystery
that's what she was you go girl i
support
it literally goes and i'm like phoebe
did it like such a good job and it just
goes whitney's friend like yeah
i just did i did um just for laughs last
year when we could do shows
yeah and um i was jonathan f jonathan
vanessa was with me
and jonathan vanessa is in an suv
with guards walking around it with a
guard in there with him a big black suv
i'm riding behind him in a gown and a
corset in a dolphin
you're pulling yourself in a ball heart
and i was like
it will never be what you think it is in
terms of of drag in general like the
sport of drag um is
comics like who are i think thought of
for the most part stand-up comedians i
thought it was like
oh you're the like oh i can never do
what you do that's what i this is you do
the scariest thing in the world
like drag to me that's where i go i
could never fucking do that you know
what's funny i
love balls i always wanted to do stand
up and then through college i was always
like
this is that open mic i'm just gonna do
it next week's the week and i would
always not do it
and then i was doing drag and it's so
funny because i used to be just a lip
sinker you know
and um one night this naked trans woman
who's in the cast
you know in drag you get very
comfortable with naked bodies right and
uh
she's gluing fabric to her body to hide
her everything
and she's like you gotta stall you gotta
take the microphone just like i have to
go talk to the audience and i went out
there and it was like
rolled right off the tongue and then i
came back and she was like you're really
funny you should do like more talking on
the microphone
and then i had done like all drag queens
do stand up without calling it standing
right right
100 our bits we have to be comfortable
improvising
we have our list of stories or hack
jokes to tell
i'm going to say something that's very
controversial which is i think drag is
more entertaining than stand up because
it is stand up
plus the visual you know what i'm saying
these are visual roast jokes
like this that's what this is so like
whenever like
that you're roasting uh uh sort of like
femininity
it's like you're roasting your own
gayness and you know in america
a man expressing himself in a feminine
way is the ultimate
subversion of power like it's the most
taboo for you to be a man and do
something feminine because
oh yeah yes there's no positive word for
being a feminine man but there's tons of
being like a masculine girl
yeah i'm boy homophobia it boils down to
anti-women-ness
yeah there's something a man being
anything like a woman is the problem so
like it's all linked
and i guess with drag it's more like
well like i'm also six feet tall
and white skin with a shaved head it's
not exactly the look for comedy
nowadays so like the great thing about
being tricksy especially
right there exactly a lot of stuff i'll
go to the captain a lot of white men
have been canceled there's a lot of
slots
yeah available there's plenty to go
around have you ever done
stand up at a gay bar not in drag no but
i've done the most difficult thing i've
ever done in my life
i've done it in shows like i've tested
material at gay stand-up nights
and it's fine but i'm also in drag
because getting gay men to clap for gay
men or gay men to say and that person's
funny possible
the velvet rage thing right can you
explain that so it's like gay people
kind of like thinking somebody else
can't be good without saying i'm less
good
because exactly so many spots it's
because of the scarcity complex right
like what as a female comedian me 15
years ago was like
female comics we were so competitive
with each other because it was me or you
like yeah
you were talking about that yeah you'd
never met and it was like a weird
rivalry based on me
yes that's a very gay mentor i mean i
used to perform at gay bars in nashville
and like you could hear pins dropped
nobody would make a sound and i would
get off stage and they would be like
that was so funny it was so good we
really enjoyed it but it would not would
not give you the time of day yeah gay
people because gay guys watch
things like whatever i'm funny too but
then you put the wig on and they're like
oh that person is um honestly that
person's submitting to us in a way by
being more ridiculous and more gay than
us
so we can kind of lift them up because
they're not threatening
it's a lot yeah it's a lot fine with it
but it's true it's like i mean i think
about the ways that i've as a
woman can torture myself into this
business to make other people
comfortable and like
you know the uh uh even now you're
taking your top off and there's no
producers here
there's no casting no one's straight
here like it's not even
like no one that wants to fuck a woman
is it even even here
um but uh you know he's i was sweating
and i'm getting a new shirt it's on the
way you were sweating through a shirt
with no sleeves
true like truly um what perfume did you
wear in high school
um god like axed body spray
that i got from the family dollar in
crevice wisconsin that my mom still buys
me every year for christmas
with your money he buys me bod man or
axe body spray man oh my god
but you know what nowadays i mentioned
real flat with her my mom is you know
she's not a woman with a lot of money
and i'll just say i want razors
and makeup wipes she delivers every year
because she's like that's perfect i
shave constantly and i use makeup wipes
constantly
just give me that neutrogena gillette
thank you i love that
because you know my family i don't know
about you but my family knows so little
about me sometimes that they're like
remember 12 years ago when i walked in
and you were watching the office so now
every year you're getting a
the office merchandise for christmas
like they they know so little about me
they're like
he has a head right yeah well that's a
hat perfect
you know like it's you're just frozen in
time that one yeah
it's fine that's so true i don't expect
that there's something sweet about that
kind of
plus i stunt on them with christmas
gifts and i'm you know i bought my house
this year for christmas so she's
she's fine i watching a documentary i
cried many times
oh really yes i cried many times at your
um documentary because uh
you know moving parts moving parts on
netflix or on itunes my the producers
would prefer it if you bought it on
itunes i'm sure but
was there anything that was cut out that
you wish wasn't
um no there's stuff in there that i
i left in knowing like i'm gonna hate
this every time i see it
like there's a part where katya is like
you know we weren't we worked together
all the time
and there was a part where it seemed
like she was never really gonna come
back to us
and there's a part where it was the most
selfish
like self-serving like like i don't know
like a performer thinking of only
themselves and i was like what if no one
wants to see me without her
which is like when somebody's like
hardcore addiction and you're going well
how does this affect me it's like that
is
so embarrassing but also now looking
back i'm like
well maybe that's honestly what people
do think and then you do go and you feel
bad about how that affects you
mm-hmm that is kind of relatable if you
have like a friend with this
no it was to me that was the most real
shit that was truly my favorite part of
it
i think that most people in most
situations are thinking about how does
this affect me
i think that's a very human and i mean
we didn't want to
i mean we still work together continues
to work together all the time and
we didn't want it to it's not a
documentary about katya it's
a documentary about me and that was just
happened to be something that happened
during the documentaries who couldn't
not
acknowledge it yeah yeah yeah i don't
think people understand and like the the
sort of like connection between you know
i think
you are stand-up comedian so but drag
and stand up are
so similar but also drag so much harder
like
i watch watching you carrying those
fucking
bags of luggage three bags of luggage i
had my hop my guitar
my backpack with my computer flash
drives i mean it's i had to carry this
bag of makeup and it almost quit
it's a lot less thing they should have
mailed it you guys know justin
martindale well
yeah justin i remember that when i first
moved to l.a justin was like why don't
you come to the um comedy store with me
and you can watch me do a set and maybe
you can do some gigs around here
and i went with him and i went to his
house first and i watched him uh
go like this with his hair and put on a
leather jacket and he's like i'm ready
to go and
it never occurred to me normal comedians
don't men especially don't do anything
i'm spending hours before i even get in
the car to go somewhere
you know and especially when you watch
top model or um
project runway it's like on drag race
and beyond we have to
get in drag do the hair the makeup make
the costume write the jokes choreograph
the dance write the song
learn the lyrics uh book the gigs i mean
we truly have to do everything
and i will never not acknowledge it like
yeah we do a lot
we do everything you're doing and we do
it on stilts and we do it on stilts
and we do uh uh we have to be in full
hair and makeup like
i remember like in the local radio shit
like people
i think the people that really fuck with
me for a long time know this like
i used to i mean 14 15 years ago i would
fly in
the night before a local club show
and do a red-eye because that was the
cheapest right and then you drive
straight to radio yeah so you land at 5
00 a.m
in toledo and then you read it like
eight and then yeah you go straight to
you know ziggy and pussy in the morning
oh it's okay was it what was um oh was
it was it marie bamford show where it's
like so and so in the douche
you know in a radio spot and the guests
and the
and the host was like so growing up your
stepfather used to make fun of you do
you want to talk about that it was like
six in the morning oh they
always want to go and it was like this
is like the weird thing to talk about
and the more people are saying your step
father abused you
yeah and they were like we're made fun
of let's talk about it yeah they're like
did you resolve that relationship i'm
like
do you want better he died of alcohol
two free tickets to zanies and
i'm lucky enough too that by the time i
booked the radio promotion a lot of
times it's sold out so then i'm there in
a wig at 8 in the morning
it's fine i mean everybody's usually
really respectful i will say the comedy
thing's fun because
i'm lucky enough to get to do a lot of
these comedy places and so
i'll just for laughs or whatever all the
comedians know each other and then i
don't know
any of them except for like a gay and
and a girl who are like
hey they know who i am but it's always
weird because i will have the same
numbers on the tours
and then the comedians that we don't
know each other so then i'll get to do
these group things where i'm like oh my
god that's anthony justin i'm like oh my
god that's anthony anderson i'm like oh
my god
what comedians do you like i i mean it's
i have a long list i mean i
love maria i love have you seen maria's
special where she does stand up for her
parents
incredible maria bamford yes so good
maria is so good i love dana gold
my earliest memories are like me
stealing ellen's albums on limewire like
here and now and taste this was just
like oh remember when ellen did that
remember ellen's joke about uh when you
get shampoo and it's in the back of it
says a quarter size
can it be two dimes and a nickel so good
and obviously sarah like when i saw
jesus's magic yeah i grew up playing
guitar i thought i want to be a musician
so when i saw somebody combine stand up
with a guitar it was like a light bulb
i guess people like ellen and people
like sarah where they're smart enough to
know what their
sound and their look is and how does
that inform the delivery
yeah like sarah is like doe-eyed and so
everything seems innocent
yeah the materials rock very smart right
and like ellen
everything is like she plays that this
person's really dumb and having
revelations on stage
because she's kind of an idiot yeah yeah
and i guess with drag too
isn't that drag you design a look to
match your voice or to juxtapose
yes and once i realized like well if i
want to tell these like dirty sort of
off-color
dark jokes this super happy big look
is there it's like the cushion and then
how do you like barbie doll saying like
crazy yeah barbie doll you pull the
thing on the back and it talks about the
divorce like i'm into that yeah
it's our job to surprise people so how
can i take them all the way this
direction
blue hair with your so that's the thing
is that now
like with this i now have to go like
straight
clean yeah my next special i'm going to
do uh try to do totally clean
oh you should i'm going to try that's my
minute you got like your clean special
and then do the photo shoot like soap
and stuff
it's really hot though like like soap
bubbles on the titties and like they're
still censored
like this is my clean special because
yours are always real provocative
named yes maybe it's like you know
whitney cummings i'm going to suck a
dick today
it's always something like that she said
yes maybe maybe when you're coming
differently it's like it's all blown out
whole
your girlfriend you're like ripping your
chest open yeah i love you i like
really jarring uh uh
let's get a brain in your son call it
tick tock i don't like yeah
i don't like funny names for stand-up
specials
i mean like i don't like it to be too
because your last name's coming you're
like it's too much i mean that's the
thing
is that having a last name coming i
don't know hey really my last special
was skinny legend which was
just a joke but i was like let's just do
that it's like so good
i mean i'm so fucking good myself skinny
is the stupidest thing in the world
and it's just like and to call yourself
a legend is the stupidest thing in the
world when's your birthday
august 23rd drag queens are lucky though
because we're afforded a certain amount
of vanity
without if you're a normal person saying
like i'm skinny and a legend you're like
you're crazy
yeah you're like rappers like female
rappers can talk about how much money
rappers know how much money they have
yeah all these things they have it's
like normal normal
like a traditional comedian is like
i'm rich people are like gross like
don't you say that
versus drag queens being like the most
important person alive is here yeah and
she's like
yes and yeah believe that sure i believe
it well she love it when you say
delusional confidence is addictive
it is and it's essential people go to
see drag to watch delusional confidence
100 i mean this is all secondary what
you really watch is to watch someone
believe it the fantasy believe it even
on drag race and friend rupaul i'm like
you're cute but you can't tell me
anything because it's i mean psycho
it's psycho to believe in yourself that
much but it's also inspiring because you
know under this i'm just like a
not pre-possessing white guy from the
midwest it's like
but it's still fun to watch someone
paradise what you think a confident
beautiful famous rich person is yeah
have you ever cried through a
performance
and no one like during a performance i
cried during my own all me too
you're adele
when i'm singing the song sometimes like
in moving parts the song moving parts
and i always kind of maybe get a little
too into it but when i cry doing other
people's things no like when you cry
like i have cried
on stage during a set because i didn't
think it was going well or i was just
like not
i wanted to because what breakdown you
ever had a breakdown once you've never
had a breakdown
once you're on stage never had the lisa
lempinelli
remember that oh that was like i've
never had that lash out on the audience
i've never done that thank
because once you're on stage you're
there's no uh this is we can
documentaries podcasts we can get up we
can take breaks but once you're on stage
and there's a couple thousand people
standing there like you're there
you're there there you're there that
clock runs until you've got a good
you know hour and a half when you're on
that stage i don't know about you but i
have the problem of
if it doesn't go my way in the first few
minutes i have such a hard time
recovering me too
and also it's that thing you know it on
paper
the audience has all different types of
laughs some people are silent and they
love it some people are laughing and
they don't think you're that great
so when you don't get that laugh in the
beginning it's so hard for me to not be
like
it's one of those nights it doesn't have
to be i let the audience
choose the terms too often that's my
they decide what the show is going to be
based on how loud they're in the first
few minutes and then it's like well
that's not your job yeah your job isn't
to do a good show
if they laugh immediately yes your job
is to that's why the national troops
are the ones where you have seven people
and you have a case of the fuck it's and
you're like i'm on fire
yeah because you're just saying anything
and everything do you feel the same
delusional confidence when you're not in
drag because i feel like for me
watching drag queens has made me feel
like like when i put on this jacket i'm
like you can't tell me shit
yeah right like and i feel like i've
learned that from just watching like
valentina or someone just believe
what she is saying i feel like to me
trixie's uh like a separate thing like i
feel like walt disney
about mickey mouse i love it i'm proud
of it i invented it
but like and then i get to be mickey
mouse sometimes but i still feel
proud of like that thing you know yes
but i don't walk around like i'm much
more of a hider out of drag like
sunglasses hat hoodie
i'm just just trying to vibe no one look
at me just trying to find just trying to
fly
yeah and what like if someone asked me
this the other day and i thought it was
an
interesting question it annoyed me at
first and then i was like i really want
to be able to answer this in an elegant
way like what won't you joke about
nobody i truly idolize uh-huh cares if
you
were offended by what they did so then
i'm like yeah i want to be like this
person i love because they don't care
yeah you know yeah that was nice and
then when i hear people like you
people who are like comedy you know up
there and when i when i remind myself
that they get cancelled and it will
never go away and it's common yes and
also
people like i was talking to iggy zell
about this people want to see a plane
take off and they want to see a plane
crash
you can't get cancelled and people don't
talk about you or think you have rich
money
yeah yeah yeah so like if you plan on
being successful plan on people being
critical of everything you do yeah and
it's also
it's not real it's not real it's talking
about it like it's like 200 people
but because and i say this all the time
like to to remind people which is like
um comics is like you know we it is our
job to ample
amplify criticism that's how we get
better because we're insecure and we go
i don't care a thousand people one
person is not laughing that's the only
person i care about
right yeah i'm saying so that's how we
get better the fact that we are
having this reaction to cancer culture
but it's also we have um
what is it well with cancer shoe i
always think about the fact that we live
in a world a lot of people that are
really into cancer culture
are people that have never they're born
they've never lived in a world outside
of this one they weren't around for the
2000 the 90s also
when i was watching like chelsea handler
and you and joan rivers and i was like
you can say whatever you want about
people
and i was like that's the kind of comedy
i want to do and then now these people
are going up with like
a very different version of comedy in a
very different world but it's also it's
not their job to not try to cancel us
it's our job to ignore them
why are we taking them seriously i was
talking about drag queen about this and
she was she has this amazing saying that
i use all do you care what beth from
iowa thinks
what are you doing she's talking about
you it is what if you had told me when i
when when i was a matter of fact if you
had told me when i was fucking
11 years old and watching paulie shore
on mtv
and like watching rupaul on fucking the
beach house or whatever the fuck
right that in 25 years beth from where
i was iowa was gonna hate my fourth
stand-up special
i would have sucked everybody's dick and
you know what the main thing is
it becomes about you have an obligation
to
perform your best for the people who do
like you so when you let
people in you're actually just hurting
your process
and hurting the people who love what you
do i the people that don't fuck with me
that's what i say you don't fuck with me
you never fucked with me
it's fine like i'm here for the people
that have always fucked with me i could
be killed half the people in this
country would have me killed for
dressing like this in the first place
i didn't start doing drag for people
like me this is the most offensive thing
you can do
it's cross-dress it's bloody it's sexual
it's offensive it's gross it's grotesque
like this i didn't start this because i
needed everyone in the room to agree
with it
and so then i have to remind myself like
bitch you do drag why did you care if
that person walked out of your shirt so
yeah
that's walkouts all the time i'm like
then i guess you didn't know what you
were coming to didn't you this was the
point
yeah that's what i always thought my i
go i wrote all these jokes to try to
make people think and uh provoke people
and make them
sort of change them and make them not
like shock them and then
when i do that i'm like what you don't
like like
for me i hate the word retarded and i
never am for making fun of people with
any sort of intellectual disability
yeah maybe at a roast yeah but like even
in my shows you mean like autism
asperger's
yeah like even when people say like
that's retarded
and i say don't say it and i still like
i i had an employer once who said it i
said uh can you not say that and she's
like
oh do you have like a sister or brother
or something i'm like no
we're at the mall and you just said
something's retarded mm-hmm so no
yeah like i when i was
no i i personally have no line i say
whatever
when i was um i was playing basketball
in high school and i did some and i was
like whatever 16 and i said like i was
like oh so you're so retarded
and then someone said to me my brother's
retarded like
it changes everything it was like it was
just like a what's the same as like
that's gay that was a huge yeah forever
and it was like
what are you saying and i was like well
why would i say retarded if
and then be mad if someone says that's
gay same thing yeah
it's interesting i have a line i i mean
i won't talk about like
politics or airplane food because i just
think it's boring yeah you know what i
mean
like the new comedy joke after 2020
though is going to be remember airline
food
remember airlines remember airlines like
i love lady bunny she's i'm one of my
favorite drag queens she has a special
a dvd called rated x for extra retarded
i would never call a special bat does it
mean i hate lady bunny no
it's like when kevin hart when kevin
hart got in trouble for that gay joke or
whatever i was like
i still laugh my ass off at the whole
special i can not like one joke
yeah i still like the rest also we want
everyone to change so much
constantly we're like do better do
better but then as soon as you get the
opportunity to better well you're
cancelled
but it's also we need contrast so it's
also it's like i go to the grocery store
and i don't buy
most of the stuff there if you don't
fuck with me like that's totally fine
but i can't start deteriorating like
what i do and letting you get in my head
because you were never buying tickets in
the first place we are taking
advice from people that never bought
tickets in the first place
what are you doing the more you stay
true to what you're doing and you keep
doing it the more people are
gonna be like oh why can't i get it now
your job is to deliver really potent
content to people and let them
remember what they loved about it forget
what they didn't like about it very
conscious only your job i have a very
controversial question for you what is
this mike
you canceled what's your favorite city
to perform in
oh um i mean maybe your hometown because
it's your hometown but
i i like la is that awful no i don't
know like
when the tourists come i bet la's we
usually end the tour is in la and so i'm
like really warmed up i know the
material and i know that there's
my friends they're industry people and
i'm always just like i'm just like
vibrating yes um i like that i also like
like as far as comedy anything in the uk
because those people have dark
well that's the thing they will laugh at
anything australia they will laugh at
the worst shit you've ever said
best um and then uh that's that's
pretty much my favorite yeah the rest of
the world honestly because america's so
like
first of all you're filming things you
shouldn't be filming and then you're
taking a clip of something you thought
was offensive and it's
it's all just i'm not even that
offensive that's the thing at all i'm
not like a bianca where i don't
my shows don't have like and i don't
joke about anything that isn't personal
so like one time i had a girl come up to
me after a show and was like
um she came out to the tour bus she
falled down a dark alley to a tour bus
and she was like i need to return your
shirt and i said oh do you need a
different size and she said no you made
a joke about sexual abuse and as a
survivor i just can't be a fan of yours
anymore
and it's like well i'm pretty openly a
survivor of that
in the show i'm talking about my own
abuse who are you to tell me how to
process and talk about my own situation
that's right people loved a hall monitor
so also you followed me down a dark
alley mm-hmm
you're also did you learn anything
you're a predator
yeah yeah right what do you think for
this one you're about you're about to be
abused again
you're like i'm a woman you can just
follow me down alley but it's also
like you're about to get raped again
bianca puts it really well she says when
somebody says they're disappointed
from a joke she told she says what she
hears is
that this wasn't what you thought it was
and you found out and that's okay you
never have to see me again
that's all it is in 1978 when hair was
on broadway
and hair had rock music homeless people
in the cast interracial kissing
lesbians if you went to the play and you
didn't like it
you would maybe go to brunch the next
day and go like oh it's a little over
the line for me
it was some of it was a little tough it
was crazy yeah yeah you don't go to the
stage door and go i saw something they
didn't like
i'm waiting my apology yeah as a viewer
as an audience member
your recourse is pretty slim you saw
something you didn't like
i guess you just go home and you tell
people you don't like it like no one
owes you anything
i don't want people deciding what's okay
for me to see
do you know what i mean yes don't worry
it's a show where we've made sure
nothing's offensive i'm like well i'll
decide what was offensive because then i
also get people to come up to me and
they go oh my god you made that joke
about getting raped that
is the first time i've ever laughed
about something like that so i get a lot
of that
as well and i'm just sort of like i
don't you know it's interesting that
our job is to um
you know uh obsessively
care about feedback and what they think
yeah but then as soon as we get off
stage we have to stop
filtering yeah i mean yeah joan river
should say all the time she's like
comedy
if you don't laugh if you don't laugh at
all the tragic stuff where would we be
yeah i'm hoping with biden i'm hoping
that this chasm of hypersensitivity
erupted
the last eight four years four years
it's like i'm worse i'm hoping with
biden
with the world being a little more safe
people will feel a little more
comfortable moving that line back to
like yeah we could have had this
conversation before but everyone can
it says it's none of it's real in
america everyone loves it it's like
what is it 22 percent of people are on
twitter of that two percent generation
eighty percent of the comments none of
it
it's only real in the sense of like if
you're
making your living off of these
platforms like instagrammers or
youtubers or
things like that you you have to have a
a give and take of like i am hearing
your feedback and i'm adjusting to it
without changing
yeah everything if you haven't done
something illegal there's no such thing
as being cancelled yeah
in my you do have to learn the hard way
a little bit and this year i definitely
was like
at the end of the year i was like all
the times i thought i was like in
trouble or whatever i was like
it's so your own perception
we now interrupt this chaos
to talk about the most important thing
to me food
i am so lazy when it comes to food
i cannot believe it 38 years old i am
still such a brat about eating healthy
i'm such a i'm just a brat i'm realizing
i'm a bratz doll
you're not a bratz doll you'll probably
be a do you think
i'm just saying like well it's a lot
easier with daily harvest
i'm just saying daily harvest is made
for someone like me someone who's a brat
who's like i'm
look i've never figured out how to eat
healthy i'm not gonna do it i'm never
gonna do it
i'm not gonna learn how to cook i refuse
like it's made for an invalid like me
i love the idea that our sponsors pay us
so that we can we can just build up this
tension of what the ad is before we tell
them the middle of the thing
they're like okay it's food related
they're trying to guess they're like is
it who could it be
well i like to set the stage because i
don't just take any sponsor
well it is daily harvest and they are
awesome there we have some
products you want to hold them up hold
on uh listen they have this is the flat
bread
no but daily hearts this is the thing
they're it's made for people that are
like it's healthy on the go ready food
yeah if you're a trash person like me
and do not take care of yourself
just honestly if you have daily harvest
in your life
this morning what's you had this one
this morning is so good i love that
cauliflower it's like it's like um that
expensive oatmeal but it's already at my
house you know what
you know what it is it's like it's like
having um groceries
parents oh daily harvest is like having
parents
that care about you and love you that
like made pre-made meals for you it's
like what our parents should have been
doing this whole time this is like if uh
this is like if gwyneth paltrow was your
parent that's right
that's what this is it's the healthiest
cleanest best version true
if you there's no mcdonald's trips here
okay this is
basically if you order daily harvest
it's like as if gwyneth paltrow was
preparing you daily smoothies and
oatmeal
i'm sure we can say that i'm sure we can
loop her in
uh but it is they deliver it right to
your house it's all healthy it's easy
ready to use there's a fl we have a flat
bread here too i'll just take it
oh this is a flat bread which i did eat
um and this is the box
but it's it's kombucha and sage
what and the flour i know you could put
kombucha on a flat bread that was a
liquid
they soaked this flat bread in kombucha
for me it was delicious
it's cauliflower kombucha squash also
didn't know that was a thing
let me just tell you this just in i'm
being heckled by our
kind of sort of asian producer this is
called what's it called
that sounds okay because i it's cambodia
i was like i don't think daily harvest
is just pouring kombucha on flatbreads i
don't think they got
wasn't that a better visual i don't
think they got that sloppy anyways you
can do the research on that yourself
look at this and they put it in a paper
um yes
everything cleaner so everything's
recyclable yes so you're not
uh wasting a bunch of you know in the
tupperware when you have to take it and
bring it home
and it's like and then you have to clean
it and you leave it at work it's a
nightmare
they've just like solved every problem
that i've ever had with having to bring
lunch to work
yeah it feels like you ordered to go
through it but you did it you made it
yourself and you can get started today
go to dailyharvest.com and enter promo
code good for you
to get 25 off your first box that's
promo code good for you
for 25 off your first box at
dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com you know fashion is my
strong suit
i'm known for my fashion yeah you're the
vivian westwood of comedy
the courtney lovacony let's be honest
um i cannot be trusted to buy my own
clothes i'm learning
that is uh is this why we that's sad
kind of is this why he's
stitch fix is a sponsor yeah you've
really come to a place where you need
robots to do everything
well i'm just saying like i can't be
left to my own devices like
i you're like hoping we live in an
algorithm you're like please
somebody this stitch fix is
it's incredible it feels like an
intervention frankly six fix is is
if you ever if you just don't like going
to the mall if you just don't like
online shopping if you don't like
putting looks together they handle it
there's like these personalized stylish
you go on their website
you take a handful of questions they're
easy questions there's no pressure it's
just like do you like to shop yes no
maybe
well it's like having a personal shopper
like there's no shame in not being a
professional stylist like i'll buy
things online
i mean there's also no shame in having
no style but i'm just saying that's
your fault stitch fix like i'm into this
company
because i don't want to have to think
about what i'm wearing i don't want
like i'm just at a point where it's like
i've just i have um decision fatigue
you know they say that like to be clear
just so stitch fish didn't come for us a
lot of whitney's outfits she puts
together on her
own even if the clothes came from there
so let's let's not put that on them
i'm just saying stitch fix is like a
personal stylist
in a box it comes to your door you can
try the pieces you need
because let's be honest we making when i
go
shopping online i want to buy the like
this
dumb thing that's four hundred dollars
fantasy i want to buy the fantasy but
i'm gonna wear once
stitch fix is like here are the staples
here's what you actually need yeah and
you can tell them if you really love
something if you want to add more of
that
type of style and your like little
resume chart they keep up with yeah
um it also shows you visuals of the
outfits you can say i like this or not
yeah i mean i i just think it's a you
know and you just pay a 20
styling fee for each box which gets
credited towards pieces that you keep
i just feel like we've spent so waste so
much time worrying about what we're
wearing keep what you love you return
what you don't stitch fix has free
shipping easy returns and exchanges
and a prepaid retr return envelope
yeah is it envelope or envelope it's uva
loopy
so get started today at stitchfix.com
get started today at stitchfix.com
whitney and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.comwhitney for 25 off
when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com whitney stitchfix that was
not made people list they were like
fuck um did you go to your high school
prom
yeah it's king what yeah i was king of
the prom i nominated myself
i lost by two isn't that fierce so sorry
well we didn't want to surprise you but
we have your whole high school class
who is the prom queen uh i don't even
remember
i don't even remember isn't that sad
fairy
why would you because you're so young
exactly i just nominated myself and like
prom king wasn't cool
once i was like listen i haven't said
i'm gay this is a class of 30 people
so i'm just gonna win can you just vote
for me great can you go from great it
was like a class of 30 people too
it was like nothing oh and i got rid of
as soon as i moved to the city i was
like i don't want this crown i threw it
away
yeah the dry craze crown now that's
better oh so much
what are you scared of uh
you strike me i'm so fiercely jealous of
you i'm so
fiercely like uh because of my body
because your body beauty breath breasts
all of it because you're just like so
much more natural like my body yeah
like what because i i just what scare
like is there
what scares you um i mean is it
relatable content to say nothing
i mean i'm not yes i mean especially in
drag nothing scares me
nothing when you're a drag you're in
your um with a shiel
human shield yeah nothing scares me
obviously i get scared of disappointing
myself of like let's say um
trying something that doesn't work or
putting on a makeup product that flops
and i'm like oh shit or um
i don't know putting out an album and
having it not reach the expectation i
want like
letting myself down professionally yeah
spook for me but it hasn't happened yet
so
how long have you been with your boy
almost five years wow
the more you put out and the more you do
the more does that fear go away
yeah the more i'm like uh like my first
record i was like oh my god i used all
my own money this could be
so embarrassing and such a flop and i
remember i landed in the uk and it was
on the charts and i remember being like
i got about mind blown mind blown that's
probably amazing
and then um yeah my boyfriend i've been
together like five years and
we have a lot of uh like he produced
that film about me yeah
and um we have a lot of projects coming
up uh but i don't really get scared of
anything i don't know i spent a lot of
my life scared
up to 18 i was scared every day all the
time and
that like home my stepdad my family the
world and then honestly like once i
started doing
at like 1918 i was like oh my god that's
all
gone uh-huh i'm never scared i mean i
know that's not relatable no it's it's
i feel bad because i feel like you can't
be in entertainment without being like
clearly disappointed because here's me
and i'm like normal
i don't have an addiction my family's
fine here's my problem it's like this is
what i always talk about and i get in
trouble in this podcast i'm like
you know you're allowed to not have an
anxiety disorder or
i like i know it's very trendy to like
have lyme disease right now like
you don't have to be a victim all the
time yeah and honestly like a lot of
horrible things have happened to me but
i have seen it all as like i talk about
in the movie like
yeah i take a lot of pride in being
somebody you would think had a totally
normal everything
you know yeah you don't have to you you
i think
it's like me too vhs you keep willfully
replaying
you don't have to be for gay kids i
think that's really that's very
relatable because there does come a
point like you said when you started
dragging like i know when i just stand
up for the first time it's like
everything just you're like oh i'm in
control of how people
of how i feel about what people are
saying about me it's like and i think
especially gay kids they all have this
like moment where they're like they find
something whatever it is dance whatever
whatever gay thing they like and then
it's like they're like this is my thing
yeah basket weaving they're like this is
it now i'm in control of this thing
it's not that bad anymore yeah i mean
drag dragon and and
growing up playing guitar and writing
music i just think i had a lot of
healthy outlets
yeah so like nothing's pent up nothing's
unresolved and my abuser died of
alcoholism so
a lot of that is just like so you won
you won yes like i think if he was still
alive out there it would be like harder
but this person's like in a box in the
ground somewhere and i don't really
think of any of it
that is such a like i need to hear this
this is like i'm this is blowing
my mind because i'm like oh my things
you have to unpack everything you have
to like
always like admit what's broken about
it's just like sometimes you just gotta
be like
people just have to die that's the trick
to kill people people die you put them
in the ground you're like okay you up
time capsule
benton does this too like we'll be
talking to drop some like horrible
tragic thing that happened
in his childhood i'm like why wasn't
that your opener right
i think how is that not your instagram
bio and once you realize why don't you
want to lead with your trauma
trauma is like the least unique thing
about you everybody had something
yeah so once you're like that's not even
like worth talking about i mean
my name trixie obviously came from what
my stepdad used to call me and so that
gets brought up a lot in like interviews
and stuff but i'm like
i don't even think of it that way
anymore that's how overt i am yeah i
don't even think about that until it
gets brought up in an interview also on
the radio at 8am
you know by the douche it's also not
helpful to have to
for people that are in positions like
like where
the public can see them to always be
like i'm sad i'm depressed i had a hard
luck because then
you're just making people that aren't
out of theirs just relive their own over
and over
and they're just like aren't you rich
whenever you could be a walking
embodiment of like
it does get better like yeah thing that
is better beauty and confidence and like
success i mean that's
has nothing to do with your trauma it
has to do with what you did after that
is there ever a time where you're like
holy shit i did it
no i mean i always try to this is like
kind of
dumb but i think everybody should do it
i was thinking this today
every time i get on stage or every time
i get in drag i always think this could
be the last time
and it really helps you be there for the
right reason because like this could be
the last time
not because you die i guess because you
die but also like work reasons this
this is fleeting i'm always like this
could be the last tour this could be the
last album this could be the last tv
show
always this could be last podcast
because it's always like
if this is the last time you do this
look how you want to look and say what
you think you want to say
and because enjoy things when they're
happening i never
think being like famous is going to last
forever i never think being financially
secure is going to last forever i save
everything i don't spend on anything
two nights ago we had a sell-out for red
scare in six minutes i walked to the
i walked to the 7-eleven and bought two
pieces of pizza for two dollars and
nineteen years and i was like this is
this is
we're doing this so i always just think
like keep one eye on the door not
because i think it's all gonna fall
apart but because if and when it does
i'm not getting caught with my pants
down
i'm gonna be like i made the most of it
i saved the money from it
i loved it while i did it and i'm not
bitter that it's over because i did the
shit of it what was happening
that's amazing and that's the t on that
business don't you think
like yeah yeah and you enjoy it while
you're doing it 100 rivers or something
you're like yeah i did it all and i'm at
the
apex of my career still i've done it all
i would like to reach a point where
i've done it all and then i can go like
do drag part time like not gig all the
time
right right right yeah she has a very
similar speech to this i'll actually
send it to you
really john where she has they're
interviewing her and she's like nothing
has promised you especially
in this business she's like she's like
you better enjoy every minute of it i
haven't saved my favorites i watch it
sometimes we're not all uppity like
you know you guys some of us are just
really thankful
the other thing is this sounds dumb i'm
training for i'm training for a marathon
but i don't talk about it what
you don't i don't talk about it into
microphones like day 20.
wow this run really taught me something
like you know i'm not that bad right
watch his britney runs a marathon one
time
right that's literally what i don't want
to be i have friends who have marathon
accounts for their instagrams and i'm
like ah
nobody cares you ran
i'm like sweating i'm dying and the
little peloton trainers in my ear and
this one girl always says
it's a privilege to move this way it's a
privilege to even be
able to be tired running right now yeah
hell yeah
and career-wise it's a privilege to have
something to do
a microphone to talk to in an unfinished
home it's a privilege to have this
problem
it's a privilege to have asthma from
renovation that's exactly oh that is my
100. it's like privileged to have a
leather jacket to pull the lining out of
to fit you know exactly it sounds dumb
it's called meaning making and it's the
thing
you it comes very natural to you and and
i've been very um
trepidatious to bring it up on this
podcast because we have a similar
come from a similar thing and all the
fans will understand that but
it's i think my trauma on a daily basis
i wouldn't change anything about the
journey like jude thank you i look back
and i'm like oh my god and then that
made me funny and then she hit me harder
oh dude
i could have been on the top of the
world i could have been i could have
been hosting
i would jimmy fallon comedians and drag
queens are so like cut from the same
club
we're the same but you're better than us
yeah you're
you're trauma but you put but you're
wrapped up in rapping trauma but cinched
i'm like lazy you i'm sloppy
lazy you well that's the great thing
about being in drag is you get to do
this high glamor fantasy
and then disappear from all that
responsibility well you make me insecure
because i'm like why would anyone come
see me if they could go see you
why would you already hear folks why
would you turn the whitney tickets now
subscribe to the balls on the beautiful
podcast and immediately buy my book
download all my albums
download barbara from 2020 it really is
a
like when i watch you perform i'm like
why would anyone come watch me and my
plaid shirt and i asked you that i asked
you that every tour why are you wearing
that shirt
sometimes i think he's a little
desperate sometimes i'm up there and i'm
i'm in a wig
in makeup in costumes with the guitar
with the band
and then doing stand-up and then there's
videos and sometimes i'm like how bad do
you want people to like you can i tell
you something just calm down
very i i'm going to say this like this
is this is why i'm comedians think i'm
co
or whatever people think i'm mainstream
or corny or come from me or i think i'm
whatever like
um want too much or whatever ugly
interrupter
obesity
[Music]
i um want people to like me i'm going to
say it
i want this audience to have the best
night of their life
no one who stands on a stage or gets in
front of a camera is like hope they hate
me you know what i've done that for me
and culture yes though but there is this
little like cool kid like i don't
fucking i'm not on fucking instagram and
i'm like no i want you to like me i want
you to think i'm funny i you don't like
that joke
how are their chicken sales who are they
who's cool just not on there yeah um
what's their names something you can't
tweet them something i've done before
that's kind of embarrassing it was at a
show and it was uh
i don't know why i knew that my dressing
room was like one door away from the
lobby door
and i was like after the show i'm
standing there in a wig and i'm
listening and me and the band are
standing there and i can hear them going
down and exit like stairs and they're
all talking
and it's like i know we're not supposed
to care but hearing people go down some
stairs being like that was
that was way better i thought it would
be or like that was so funny or like i
can't believe how good that was or
whatever it's like
i know i shouldn't care about that but
why would i not care about that yeah you
should
i don't read the comments i don't i post
on instagram and twitter and then i
close the apps i don't spend time in the
apps at all i don't refresh the timeline
don't care youtube don't read the
comments um i don't go on any like fan
websites
it's not my business
our job is to put the thing out there
and that is it well i just covered video
games last year that london del rey song
i was like well i mean we're covering a
lot of little race song i mean
people are gonna hate listen to it
they're gonna go like let's see what
this fucking idiot is doing with this
iconic song and i was like well at least
they get their listen even if they're
hate listening
they still want to tune in to see if
they hate it i would like to know
if it's possible to cover natasha
bettingfield's unwritten
i oh that is a perfect song
[Music]
oh my god is this a reveal yeah we just
brought our friend natasha over
did somebody call my name did you just
hear me say that it was a perfect song
you guys can't you guys can't see this
but natasha van gaal just walked in here
natasha
up girl and the rest is still on richard
hey
hello everyone hello wow you're
fabulous you're amazing and when you
told me you were coming on and i
i was just like sending her a video clip
on a video clip i was like
like just like bombarding you with
amazing clips of
you oh my god like i watched one thing
where you just the first
off you're like i'm a legend icon star
and i was just like yes
i said you have confidence yeah this
british girl needs a bit of that
of that kind of we were just we like
self-deprecating we were just talking
about
british audiences they're down for the
ride no matter how dark
no matter how self-deprecating they're
just like yeah let's laugh at it
so i have this dream that you two are
gonna write a song together
well i'm like the present i also think i
i also have a sneaking suspicion that
comedians and comedy writers are very
good music writers which i confirmed
that yes texting you and saying i think
you'll be an amazing writer songwriter
and i agree i also got that text message
thank you
i agree what did you say i also got the
same message from you thank you so much
i think he's kind of similar i think
joke writing and songwriting is
very because you're trying to say
something universal in a way that hasn't
been said
you know what i mean yes yeah yes
and it's also something that gets stuck
in your head that you
say a lot that's a good idea that like
this is the thing
this is a refrain yes think that dolly
ponton does she write her own jokes
because she's
an amazing comedian like in between all
of her um songs she's incredible she's
so funny yeah
well that's also years and years of and
this is why i defended lana del rey so
hard if you guys want to do a deep dive
on my
myspace defense of lana del rey the
first time she did
uh snl remember when how dragged of
course
and i was i was making fun of him i was
concurrently being dragged
and i thought we were like having this
like soulmate experience where we were
both being dragged at the same time
publicly like two women
because she had no live experience yeah
first it was her first
live show so when you were dolly parton
you come up in clubs in nashville
like you know how to deal with hecklers
and jokes and this and the lighting and
this and that
you know and so she went on and she had
no live presence
it happens and everybody you know
dragged her for it
i've been to several streaming awards
which is like the youtube awards and
they'll always book youtube musicians
and it's always like oh you lit you
perform in front of a camera for a
living not in front of people yes that's
right obviously
do you ever have a song that's like
hasn't worked and you don't know why or
like no
not in a second no everything she's done
well i haven't
like there's like a joke you always
tried to make work and you couldn't make
it work and you're not sure why
and you're like ah like you know like
i'm just so curious like with
songwriters like are there
those songs where you're like it's on a
post-it note somewhere it's in a journal
somewhere and you just like could never
make it crash i did try and do a comedy
song
which is called i want to have your
babies um which didn't
work people she's like i regret to
answer i was banned from the radio i was
banned from radio 2 because they were
just like
she wants all our girls to have babies
like like they took it so literally and
i was like it was totally a joke song
if people go out and get pregnant
because of that song which isn't bad
yeah it's not bad but the men were
terrified of me and i didn't get a date
for
years afterwards because the men were
like bonnie boiler bunny boiler
oh i want to have your babies get
serious like crazy
i want to have your babies i see them
springing up like daisies
and it was all about i'm gonna button my
lips so the truth don't slip
and so it's all about keeping it like
back like in a date like you don't
really tell them you're actually on a
date
trying to find the father that's covered
but you hide it back but i made a
mistake of actually telling people what
women are thinking and they did not like
that i love that yeah as musicians
what's more important to you guys the
lyrics or the instrumentals i mean i'm
sure they're all important in the end
but like what
what you have to have first because i
know when i listen to music i'm all
about the lyrics that's the first thing
i want to hear
i don't even know there's music playing
in the background interesting
i like listening songs in different
languages
so i don't have to listen to the lyrics
like i love listening to french songs on
spotify like the french play all the
um love like folks well it's like i was
listening to stand up no it's like folk
it's like if i listen to stand up i'm
like oh fuck okay he did okay
all right all right they have a me too
okay it's work it feels like work when i
hear lyrics
and i never want to like it's hard
because with stand-up because i never
want to be influenced by accident by
somebody either
so yeah it's hard because it's like i
never want to be like
it's a tricky thing but like with santa
i know that i want to have a certain
rhythm and like and like when you're
writing music because like i always like
you i feel like are such a lyricist like
you have like really great lyrics i
think it's a lot like writing jokes
yeah because it's like how do you say
this in a way that people go that's
exactly what it's like but they've never
thought of it that way it has to be very
surgical
yes you put it in the way in an elegant
way
in um seven words that
explain my life experience right seven
words i like i love like fountains of
wayne like um adam schlesinger like i
think he was like the master of pulling
a rhyme that you would have never
thought of that's like
oh my god that's exactly what it is yeah
like when someone does a rhyme
it's just like like when they get a
rhyme like
eminem does that a lot and it's just
like nicki minaj hilarious
and it's like a joke where the ultimate
compliment from comedian is when someone
goes
that's a really good joke yeah well yeah
and with lyrics too you'll go like
oh bitch that is a really good lyric
yeah it's jealousy not a laugh
yes i wish i had thought of that because
there's the forgether the together and
forever and there's this and this and
it's like yeah that's like white noise
at this point
with the way people run certain things
yeah so like a good i think if you have
a good concept then the song kind of
writes itself right
when i do stand up i start with a thing
i think is funny
and then i start like hammering out just
so it's like last special it's like i
had the robot
and i was like i had what one good sex
robot joke
and then i challenged myself to go like
i need to write two pages of these
and then i start building out a chunk
and it's interesting yeah it's sort of
maybe how music is written so i'll go
like i know i want to do something on
sex robots like i won't even have the
joke yet
because like for me i go for areas first
so you're like hmm
sex robots sex robots i want to own sex
robots
i'm saying because if i do one joke
about sex robots one joke about them
it's like needs to be a chunk for it to
be actually put into the show milk it
yeah
and no one can steal your shit if you
have
the um monopoly on it i'm saying so it's
like
i want to show up and do 10 minutes of
sex worry about jokes everyone's like
whitney's got that one and we're going
to stay away from that one did someone
go you look like a sex robot and that's
how it
yeah robots have more emotional range
than this one
this is for her time working as a sexual
yeah yeah it's a robot and a martial
field
she's an ally yours if somebody went
this drag
yeah and i
and i'll do like an air like a theme and
then
and so i uh so i'll do a theme and then
stick to
and then i'll write down words every
word that is associated with robot
frank you know like kid robot um small
wonder
um like i'll just write down every word
like i have a document of it and then
start digging in and then go from every
angle and then i'll go into chat rooms
uh of people that have it like i have
like a whole kind of process now of how
i do it
do you remember when dancing on my own
came out it was a cultural reset
her and that blue sweater just rolling
oh my god that whole album it's one take
attempts i
you're giving us gold on how to become
comedians oh yeah no please
everybody at home follow this i don't i
mean it's no
uh like as if there's ever have you ever
heard of lists
it's a lot of those i invented this
thing
refer to them later in order sometimes i
put numbers by them sometimes small dots
patented can i tell you something about
bullet points
i'm sorry can i see any of your fucking
jokes written down on something
most comedians do not write shit down i
will write it down for like
a year and then at the end of the year i
write all the jokes down that i wrote
and i put them on the wall and index
cards like i'm tracking a murderer ooh
border board and then i take all the
looks i'm inspired by and i put wigs and
costumes on the ward like a murderer
and then there's all the songs i wrote
that year and i put them on the wall
like
murderer can you help us make alter egos
oh my god alter ego is a great song
title alter ego also eager
do you write down song titles yeah so
then it's the same it's the same like
all song titles alter ego
what makes you who think what makes you
think of an altar suicide notes
no i just write and you just write it
down yeah i have suicide notes you're
like
my phone notes are very difficult okay
sorry everyone starts with goodbye
thank you for i'm a millennial so it's
not your fault
not a lot to live for i swear it's not
whitney's like okay here's one of my
jokes i wrote okay i'm sorry to everyone
in goodbye
oh that's sorry wrong note anyway next
one
i've waited so long power of attorney i
need to buy
condoms oh sorry that's a different list
are you writing a song yes my theory on
songwriting
cause i think sometimes i can say things
in a way that are kind of like elegant
and profound
and sometimes i do and i'm like i don't
know what that was i don't know where
that goes and it's not a tweet and it's
not a joke but it's like
she said somebody saw that at cracker
barrel put on a piece of wood like it's
a pillow is this something we put on a
pillow is this a quote is it a fortune
cookie
or like the metaphor is usually what
starts it right yeah something that's
plain that gets thrown out all the time
and you're like well there's a double
meaning
know well because i find that when i get
in fights with guys
um i go i'm not fighting with you i'm
fighting for you
that's that's right that's probably
makes the argument worse doesn't it
she's like you know what your room's not
finished yet and i might not finish it
at all exactly
fully have a sperm donor on ice like you
know always win because you'll win win
like you're a win-win person so you
always make sure that you both win
in a way yeah exactly i'm not like he
wins two right if you
win yeah we both lose so let's make sure
that this you know what i'm saying oh i
would be like if you're fighting for me
then you're wrong right because i think
you're wrong don't fight for me
pretty sure if you're fighting for me
you're doing it wrong yeah i'm awful
don't fight for me so that's not how you
the cause you two are my two favorite
songwriters i'm just
say in one place so i'm i'm bombing
uh you just start with titles you don't
start with like profound poignancy no we
say we
it's not just titles though that can
just be a springboard like you're trying
to like saying she's like
first line like you like that's what
starts me yeah
and i think the first line needs to
encapsulate the whole song like
sometimes the whole song needs to just
be already
there in the first line yeah like when i
wrote moving parts it was like i didn't
think people would it would become such
like a thing that people listen to but
i was like oh the the most parts of your
life that are the most like out of your
control that are moving around
are the parts that are the ultimately
the most moving like that that change
your life the most and i was like oh
there's a metaphor i like it and then i
went into it that was like an instance
where you start with the metaphor
but then like mama you could put on the
dress again that was just that's the
first line because that's what i was
i was in a theater i had to get in
dragon i didn't feel like it and that's
it
and there's like not deeper intellect
besides like not wanting to work
i wrote a song called i bruce easily and
i actually literally bruise these i
actually have very pale skin and i
everybody had just fallen down the
stairs
all the time like every time i would
come into the studio i'd have another
bruise
and i'd be like you really i was like i
bruised easily and they were like
they're like are you okay you're like is
everything okay at home
totally and i mentioned it in an
interview and they're like she's got a
condition where she
i'm like no it's just called being very
very white
but hollywood needed you to have a
condition like she is broken
no she's in a cast are you okay i was
just thinking about this recently
obviously there's the celine dions of
the world and people who are just like
the michael phelps of singing right like
natural
but i think so much of singing is just
intention it's almost like acting
so if you sing it like you mean it
that's always going to be more impactful
than
technique yeah hey i have a question for
the group what are your favorite music
videos you can pick one
ooh i like a i i i want to start an
award show of
best videos
i want to start a business about this
it's called mtv
yeah best music video ever it's called
mtv oh best music video is that what
you're doing yeah what's your favorite
your
favorite you could watch one forever
okay you started
working i think about it
black hole sun that is a cool one black
hole son
did jerry cassalli direct that or um
that's what all the smiling people right
why
you're so funny natasha you start okay
so mine is black hole stunned
natasha stop talking about buddy head of
black hole son natasha finds
i think that probably everything by
michael jackson
but then i have to say lady gaga i
really did actually revive the whole
music video see i love two girls one cup
oh my god the one that brings me joy the
most probably i
the love shaq video is so fun oh it's so
funny it's so fun you know what came to
my head immediately when you asked this
question remember the band dream
picking petals off a flower trying to
get you oh yes yes i love that music
video
those girls and those like little shorts
they're driving that jeep yes
cannonball nope uh the breeders i like
cannibal by miley cannonball
hear me like a cat wait it's wrecking
balls
growing up yeah that's what that did you
guys remember the johnny cash hurt video
yeah that one is they play that and then
johnny cash museum on a loop
still moving song we're writing a song
we're on track writing a song
and what what let's make them a lot of
money right now
and make a song so uh that's how all
songs start
on the spot on a podcast i'm super
stressed
this is how dolly wrote i i love you
this is jolene was written
in this exact scenario yeah in a bank
song
let's make money yeah yeah always like
money and always someone telling me
we're doing it now
and there is no instruments i want to
make a show about this
can you beatbox
i have a deviated septum i can't take
that much air in the best part i can't
beatbox i can barely breathe good
the best part is me going whitney why
don't you want me to bring my guitar
because i wanted to be a surprise that's
the more important part of writing a
song
no instruments the element of surprise
michael jackson did thriller with
instruments no i really want to learn
how to write a song
you know what i'm saying like i'm
re-learning how to write jokes because i
want to start writing jokes in a
different way we really do need to
we're going to calm down instruments to
write a song okay i didn't know that but
all good songs
can we use any of these only an
industry professional who seasoned would
know that there's instruments involved
but natasha if we just start singing
we'll
we'll i think i think music will just
cue up i've seen a lot of glaze
that's how it works okay my plan uh
sucks i thought we were going to
uh write a song together well let's do
our next game and we'll just go
through perfumes together okay maybe
we'll come up with more song ideas maybe
we'll get inspired
i'm learning so much here because i'm a
very intense
that's where my sharpeners go i love
this you can have it
well in that case i also like this brush
everyone goes home with everything on
the table
we now interrupt this beautiful chaos
gorgeous cats to go to take a nap i'm
going to bed
to talk to you about my favorite hobby
sleeping two two hours ago it was eating
so we're gonna
we're gonna keep up this is a podcast of
this we're gonna
be a quiz at the end of all my favorite
things yes listen this is for helix
we've talked about helix before and let
me tell you
getting out of my bed i may not do it
it is touch and go if i'm gonna show up
it is i between
the sheets and the mattress and
everything else on that bed
i may never leave it i mean we had a
mandatory 10 day
quarantine you don't have much of a
choice even then
thank god we have a helix mattress yeah
my dad growing up my dad said people
need two things in life
good food and a good bed if they work
hard if they don't want you spend what
of your life in your bed right i mean
maybe for normal
i spend like 98 we spend so much more
time in our beds now
because of the pandemic mattresses are
more important
than ever yeah and he likes you take a
quiz online you just go take a little
two-minute quiz it matches you
your body type to the perfect sleep bed
which is very important there's nothing
more
uh dude most of the damage you're doing
to your body
is at night while you're sleeping that
is what a very
famous chiropractor told me very
successful chiropractor
that's true i couldn't afford to keep
going to him at the time but he was like
all the damage you're doing to your body
happens while you're sleeping it's all
about the mattress and i remember
because i sleep on cinder block so it's
really difficult
and i remember being like okay but i
don't know how to
implement the advice you're giving me
and helix has solved that problem
yeah they'll match you i mean there's
multiple different mattresses
and they match you like we got two
different mattresses you have uh
the very very like soft one and i have
the medium firm one they have these
fancy names which i'm gonna be honestly
did not memorize um because they were
very hard to pronounce
but it worked and i buy it again he
left helix and you just go to
helixsleep.com whitney take the two
minute sleep quiz and they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you'll
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free
they even pick it up if you don't love
it they'll come back and get it helix
is the oh number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020
and by gq and wired magazine yeah those
are some
bitchy outlets the two men those are
some snobby outlets
if they think if they put them in his
number yeah if james bond will sleep on
it then
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
and the pillows are no joke either helix
you know what i want to do
i want to experiment with reading an ad
verbatim
okay let's read an advice i would love
to we usually go off the rails let's do
it benton
guys this is all the everything on the
screen we're just gonna read it
we deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why especially when it
comes to something we take every day
rituals clean vegan friendly
multivitamin
is formulated with the high quality
nutrients and bioavailable forms your
body can actually use
what you won't find sugars gmos major
allergens
synthetic fillers and artificial
colorants plus the fresh taste and
delayed release capsules design
making taking your vitamins easy now you
go
uh talk about your personal experience
and why you love ritual
i have done that before uh very much
there's no reason to not be taking oma i
have to take oma like i'm 38 as a woman
in a pandemic i only i have to take it
there's no option it's not optional for
me at this point
love your personal experience ritual is
a multivitamin reimagined
a multivitamin should contain key
nutrients and forms your body can
actually use to help fill the gaps in
your diet
no shady extras rituals delayed release
capsules designed deliver
high quality nutrients including vitamin
d3 and just two daily peels
ritual is made traceable trademark
you'll always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from thanks
to rituals one of a kind
visible supply chain ritual is designed
with your life stages in mind now
available for women
men and teens rituals all the stages of
my life
rituals and multivitamins are
scientifically developed to help support
different
life stages ritual makes healthy habits
easy your multivitamins are delivered to
your door every month with free shipping
always
and you can start snooze or cancel your
subscription at any time
and if you don't love ritual within the
first month they'll refund your first
order you read the green part get key
nutrients without the bs
ritual is offering listeners 10 off
during your first three months vis
visit ritual.com whitney
to start your ritual today i am so
over thinking calculated about stuff and
i'm really worried
i hate being thinking calculated i'm all
through college you didn't think about
instruments did you
but here's she thought
natasha we can make noise with some of
this stuff that's true yeah
what you're a musician like make it work
yeah remember when you were in stock all
those years
stumped remember remember your years of
blue man group
i dated blue man you did that
i know that's just let's just draw there
was a man and her father was a blue man
oh yeah that could see us i did the blue
man wait sorry that was black face
anyway um he's at the capitol uh
we're reporting live from the cabinet
live from the capitol
it's a mess quentin's pelosi's office
she too has half-hazardly stapled
curtains
an unfinished wall
do you love that we had this done but
he's like it's all denim people are
going to love it and i'm like
really cute on camera it's just we're
like oh no
no no no one had any clue the whole room
is denim exactly
what we thought it'd be like a cool
country western whitney loves to be like
i'm from virginia we thought it'd be a
whole thing
i i do think that a song does start with
a conversation
or a like a subject so i think this is
why natasha's rich she's not going to
let it go she's like we can do it i
ain't the best the thing that you can i
think
it's just more like a brainstorm session
and then we'd have to go into the studio
and actually get a beat
you just like write stuff down yeah i
want a costumer i can't work
you need to be in a full costume oh i do
yeah when you record you go in in hair
and makeup
no no uh wait i do have hair makeup
you're like i haven't i don't shave my
head
recording questions but do you get fancy
to go record or do you keep the real
chips
i did a lot it's like the no makeup
makeup look so right it still takes a
while
sure but like no wait do you think we're
asking you right now if you're wearing
makeup
no no not now we know no i'm saying but
what is the part of the ritual of going
in to record do you need
because you look ugly i think that she
thought you were asking her right now
no no no no no no that's not what i mean
you need it
i'm not either i'm not either me and
natasha
we're not onto we're not in makeup and
you're not you've got no makeup on brave
we just woke up like when you go to the
studio to work that day
you do do you do comfortable do you do
hair and makeup what do you do i think i
i i like something that's inspiring that
like outfit wise it has to be
comfortable that you can sit down on the
floor and just like
feel it move but i need to look i need
to feel
like you look yeah totally i recently
recorded a song in drag
and i never recorded and dragged before
it was so fun
yes it changed the delivery it changed
everything yeah you know normally it's
like you have to do it a few times then
you're like okay now i got it
but when you feel like you look great
you start that first take like we're
getting it
yes we got it yeah it's weird how the
makeup makes you feel like
we're doing this perfectly the first
time you do your own makeup on the road
um yeah yeah i love it you love it i
love it yeah i'm really good at doing
makeup in a moving vehicle
really that's a good challenge you put
your finger there
and you do that oh yeah yeah you only
get stuck in the car you're doing
something like that
yeah on the table i do like i don't know
i i did the big mirror and then the big
table and i find like i try not to sit
too close or i get too micro managey
yeah i'm like five feet away if it looks
fine from there it's probably fine
my first special i did my own makeup and
i did wear this color
she had on um show orchid from mac oh i
love that color
what was that show work orchid that's
what i wore like a metallic pink
yeah i love it unless it's the only
color you're allowed to wear
consumed with shame and i made a joke
about it and i so regret it
i was so ashamed of the makeup yes when
i came out
where'd you have it done at lancome no i
did it no my first special was my
uh was a local makeup artist in dc
i had no idea what i was really doing i
was like 26
and i was so apologetic about my
femininity
as a comedian a female comic i had to
neuter myself
so much it's interesting because it's
like i look
at the hyper femininity thing and i have
to hyper
masculinize myself in order to not have
the girlfriends in the audience
think their boyfriends want to fuck me
because everyone's on date you know what
your audience is there to see
and these are people on dates and
i've noticed that but you're doing all
the work already the date is you being
funny for them
but there's people in the audience that
are 24 years old
who are the boyfriend just cheated on
them and then there's a girl who's cute
on stage who's like why are you laughing
at her
i i've seen it so many times couple gets
up starts fighting gets up go
fight in the parking lot i've watched it
happen so many fucking times
that i dress for the women in the
audience
to feel comfortable that i'm not going
to fuck your husband
i've seen that's how i dress in in like
corporate shows
like all the and it's all businessmen
and i'm like i'm kind of being sexy and
then i'm like oh hold on they don't look
pleased and the woman doesn't look
pleased and the men are kind of going
like like we're
kind of looking but looking away and so
i just like completely changed my
approach and i was like okay
it's like saying love like this and
talked about like like when you first
fall in love and let's have couples
dance
like dance with your i think i actually
wedding dj yeah i asked her
like i asked a guy to dance with me and
then i realized that was totally wrong
and i brought his wife in as well and
like well i dress for the men and they
just can't take it
i'm like the inverse of you when i
started i was like i have to
look like a you know short ugly
irrelevant poor mean poor i like to
write jokes and tell jokes that someone
can go tell their friend the next day
at work so i'm going to give you a gift
that means that you get to go be funny
now
like i the merchandise to make it
whatever it is you get to go to work
tomorrow
and you get to go i saw whitney cummings
last night and she told this joke
and then you get to be the comedian at
work i love that because you get to
relay it
you know i never thought about comedy
like that i always think like i want to
be
the person that you look at your friend
and be like we thought that but didn't
say it
like that's what i want to do for
someone i always like to go when you
leave this performance
you're going to go i just saw so-and-so
and she said this thing that was so
funny and then you get to go kill with
your friends
but when he's still like also like so
conscious of like making sure everybody
else feels like really like good when
they're in her space
that like we had remember we had those
guests over here and they were telling
you what editing was and you were like
oh my god yeah tell me more about
editing
no no well you have to contextualize
that a little more it was steven
spielberg
it was it was the it was the kids from
cheer
and like when you have made these tv
shows and they're like so editing what
they do in editing is they can like take
a scene and they can move it so it looks
like you're saying something different
and i know when he was fully like she
was like really
that is and and and so and so you didn't
really say that then that was later and
they put it back and like to enter into
someone else's reality and they were
like yes when you're so crazy of course
i was like do you think i could be on
the tv
it is a tricky thing it's like when
someone comes up to you
i try to go when someone i'm like what
do you need from me like i always want
to give you what you need
you know because to me the people that
listen to our shows that buy our things
like they're our boss
we work for you you know and so i go
you're walking up to me i see this
person walking up to me
shaking and i'm like this person needs
something from me i just want to deliver
i want to deliver on the promise you are
the reason that i get to do what i love
and they get this close to her and she
goes i don't read the comments no that's
why meet and greets are extremely high
pressure
because you have to live up to whatever
they have decided you are yes
it's harder than performing i think meet
and greet is you could have a just okay
show and if you were nicer at the meet
and greet they're a fan for
life but but bye but if you weren't nice
enough the meet and greet and your show
was incredible they don't really
but there's also like there's no way to
and
like you've seen me at meet and greets
you're really good at it
this is how we met because it's like a
way to
move because you have to move people
along in a way that's not rejecting them
and people like my dog you're like give
me your camera i know yeah because it's
like people are like i i
um you know didn't commit suicide
because of you but and you're like i
love you you're like selfie mode selfie
selfie mode selfie mode pairs filter
thank you if you do die we'll use it at
your funeral
tag like tag me by my merch um you know
so it's like it's this delicate weird
balance where you really have to
let's get you in a bitch with your photo
i do like i just do what i really
respect thank you emily whitney is that
you you aim high
and you let your audience be very intel
like you just you expect them to be
yes you do catch up yeah and i love it
like you you
you um you attract always play to the
top of your intelligence yeah it's
really awesome i love it
i love that about you because a lot of
people are the lowest common denominator
in the world more compliments
you're so right right i remember
watching whitney on tv and i was like
well she
kind of talks strange and i talk weird
so i could do that
it was just so interesting like she was
the person that was like you can just
sound like whatever and be on stage and
that sounds really weird
but like that annoying but like i have a
lisp and you're the only community i can
think of that you don't have a list but
you you hold your esses
yeah like on only on stage only doing
comedy and i remember seeing i remember
i was like 12 or 13. now you're on
chelsea lately talking
and doing a joke and i remember seeing
that being like that sounds like me
i remember and it like clicked in my
head i could do that i could do i could
totally do whatever i wanted on stage
and that was it was like such a small
thing but it like
resonated it's not that don't just stare
at me like that i remember seeing you
being like
as a model i could do comedy too
i was at the same department store i'm
obsessed with
fragrances okay i'm obsessed with
olfactory glands
and how when we smell something it takes
us
back yeah to right where we fucking were
and i encourage everybody that is like
working on their script or their book or
their song or their
whatever your hustle is to listen to
music you listen to when you were 15
listen to a song you haven't heard and
it makes people feel things
i wish that there was a camera that
could capture fragrance
like when i'm like when i'm like
sometimes i'm in a place and i'm
capturing the picture and you just
won't be able to you won't how do you
remember that smell
like the beach smell or something it's
there's no word that describes it
there's no way i can explain this to you
that's why like the cologne you wore
when you were dating one person it makes
you think of them or their cologne like
that kind of thing
always and it can ruin a cologne yeah
but
i think i'm obsessed with when you smell
a perfume that you wore when you were in
high school and you're like all your
shit comes back
you know this is my new for my next
special i'm
smelling and i'm listening to things
that i haven't smelled or listened to in
20 years
to try to like kick up old memories like
you're smelling like too like dead
so that's your toothpaste your hair
single is called i smell
laughs tampons you can see that's not a
bill
oh my god i'm smelly still hate single
um
and like how she got the sinus infection
all the smelling
and uh and just sort of like what it
does to our brains
and makeup noxzema makeup certain makeup
products like certain smells
like covergirl clean liquid makeup is
like high school or something
mac studio fix mac studio fix lip glass
eyeliner
no hair spray yes the ellenette hair
spray is like your mom or your grandma
or something
so i want to see if you can do you get
migraines no okay
i want to see no trauma over here
i said i have no trauma and i said i ran
10 miles yesterday hit me with a smile
are you not listening to my interview i
want to do like
can you guess the smell yes we all we
both brought we both bought fragrances
okay do you guys think that i lived as a
squirt girl in an uneven marcus or
something
because i i lived it i worked at a
macy's in the midwest that was like go
ahead and try the new
vince camuto you get a free token ariana
grande
ice cream friday pink friday i bought
eight of those pink freddy
pink face well we were just going to
talk about them but now we've turned it
into a sniffing game
what do we think it is beautiful it
makes me think of
i it's kind of a cop-out but it makes
think about apartment store
it smells like white diamonds right does
it
no elizabeth arden sunflowers
oh yeah this was one more time this was
truly
i want to say 10 years of my life that
smells good
i like that elizabeth arden sunflowers
like when i smell not old lady but it's
maternal in a way
i mean it's like you could get burnt but
you're not ready well that's a huge
bottle
a huge bite who is back in the day you
got she said i've been using this 15
years when perfume bottles used to be
bigger they were
the same you just kept it you're like i
bought it 15 years ago
whenever curious is like a tick-tacker
like it's like this big isn't it like
the number one selling fragrance in the
world
it does it does look like a shot of
whiskey yeah um i like it
i probably wouldn't wear it but it's
very floral that took that was my
entire teenage i've been dry humped
today for elizabeth arden's sunflowers
correct as a teenager as a teenager
what do you think she had a tight perm
oh a string of pearls the jellies she
had the lip smackers
first of all the only girl's outfits
golden like big shoulder pads oh she was
they got in the meeting for this bottle
design and they were like we don't care
100 this is nothing they were like they
were like you know what do you have a
lid put it on
can i tell you something this was back
when you when you bought something
you got the product look how much
product is in there that is a shampoo
bottle
that is a tremendous amount of product
that is so much
lysol that is more lysol what three
memories did you wear it for can i tell
you something
uh covent stops literally i wore this
all through high school and none of it
is gone yeah how many times
that's how much is in there spending so
much time with my mom at the department
store i could have had more chances to
wear it
but it was free at the department store
so i didn't have to use my own
this is the original bottle i bought
i've been using it for
30 years and this is how far we've
gotten so it's pretty you have four
memories out of it there you go
but this is like this is back no we need
to dig it out of storage i ordered it
because i was like am i new special i
want to remember things that i have
blacked out
and perfume is the key to unlocking
memory remember something
yes i was molested as a child and no but
i truly were
yes i don't think it's ever been brought
up yeah all the time
i'm making fun of her oh i was like
really
that was so rude i'm so sorry
you guys my life's hard um but when you
smell
you go like oh fuck and you start
thinking about jokes and lyrics and
ideas
and it like jogs your memory sunflower
you can write a whole song about the
fragrance elizabeth arden sunflower
yeah and if you're using that bottle for
inspiration doesn't have to be a lot
look at this just to the bare minimum
bare minimum that's what i got out of
that bottle
i think there's something very virgil
abloh about this bottle i think it's
kind of gangster
okay so here's the next smell
ready an asm artist
this is called the most seductive
fragrance in the world i like that it
smells yummy
actually i can't like you can use this
in the future
yes it's uh it smells kind of like you
totally know it
we're not supposed to say what it smells
like which is what it makes to think of
right what is it
no there's no rules to this game it's
buttery what is it like a rum
do you know it it's like a butterscotch
yeah you know it
it makes me think of um summer a lot
like girls i went to high school with
with like spaghetti straps and like tans
and laying out by the pool
it's brazilian crush my soul did narrow
the bum bum cream it is the
it's eight dollars it's called the most
seductive scent on the bottle it says
you can spray your lingerie with it
it smells pretty yeah it does it smells
very like
i'm going straight was this hard to find
like was this no it's a sephora
yeah and you know what people love on
podcasts things they can't see or
experience
she's like this is actually nice i love
that no one's describing the fragrance
either they're just like what is it
no i just it smells clean but also kind
of tropical
what are you wearing now
where like the aveda men's like just
smells like a veda do you like floral is
that what you said
in drag yeah like yeah really hyper
feminine i mean that florida sugar
floral fruity florgasm but um
out of drag i wear like uh something
that smells like like
replica makes that one that's like a
fireplace what we were about to bring
yeah i love rubicon
i love it yeah it's amazing i feel like
a marshmallow when i wear it though so
last thing we're going to do
you have barbies here yeah we got lots
of barbies for you to talk us through
review
take home wow okay let's talk about it
because we do want to know you i don't
have a barbie i have your pop final
figurine my mom stole it so that's on
our
on our oh yes i have a vinyl we love
that i just like to do a little review
but
why do you not have a barbie and if you
did what would what would the fifth
grade be
well you never know what's in the
kitchen what's happening you never know
what's coming on the pipe but um
that's actually really nice to me and
they send me all their whenever
something new comes out they send it to
me and they're not ever trying to sue me
i actually last year got to sit down
with all the designers at barbie and
give a presentation about like my
process which was so surreal because i
was like i always thought this call
would be with legal
so you know but it was that's so cool
no that's a real laugh i thought it was
like oh god they're reaching out this is
gonna be bad and they were really nice
about it
because they were like uh we have a
whole new life thank you yeah it was
nice it was really nice um
i love barbie i have a crazy crazy
collection if you guys ever come over
hundreds and hundreds i love that i used
to be when i was when i was going to
mcdonald's i would like beg for the girl
toy because i wanted that little
barbie with that sculpted plastic hat
they're chic yeah
but i i have a very average terrible
relationship with barbie did you have
tell me about it so i think we need this
is they let the healing begin
you had a bad one that's why my mom and
dad bought me barbies they had no qualms
about it
i i did not have barbies growing up
there was there was like a microwave
barbie
moment where we would put them in the
microwave oh
maybe that's why you didn't have so you
were like she's like i didn't have
barbie it's just these great looks in a
modeling career
um no i i like i didn't have barbies we
had my little ponies and rainbow brights
and everyone else had barbies and i
don't know why we didn't get
them maybe because we kept putting them
in the microwave
sky dancers very important oh we had
rainbow bright
my little pony and i would like to work
on my relationship with barbie sky
dancers were every little gay boy's
dream look it just take off
bark gets to leave barbie's very pro
women yeah and if you think of every
barbie as like a time capsule of what
women did in war in that time they're
very cool because it always is
what women were wearing what their jobs
were at that time yes what the hair and
the makeup was
history it's a history lesson sculptures
well i watch a lot of your videos and
they are like i never even thought like
the process of like you know like about
the faces and the sculpting i'm like
whoa like i have no idea you have to
think before barbie women were only
given dolls that were babies women were
only allowed to imagine to be moms
so then you have this doll that's sexy
with boobs with no man her own apartment
her own job
her own car it was the first time women
were like i can be things
also didn't you say that for a long time
barbies didn't look straight ahead yeah
barbies used to look always to the side
like a very long enough
kind of like betty boop never looked
straight ahead like it's like a thing
they did like female figures
because she was so so then like 1971
happens like gloria steinem women's lib
begins and then malibu barbie comes out
and she's looking straight ahead because
it's like i'm here
yeah you had such a good youtube video
and i went to this rabbit hole like what
other female
like figures didn't look straight ahead
it was like so many yeah it's pretty
crazy because like women were allowed to
have curves but like not look right at
anyone like
i'm a sexy baby who can't look at him
these curves belong to someone else who
will come take them
but we brought a bunch of barbies that
are i mean they're not like they're not
as fancy as your barbies but they're
barbies who want you to tell us
like what do you think about them how's
barbies change i was in the barbie aisle
and i personally feel like
when i was little was in the barbie i
was like there is some awesome stuff
here and now i'm kind of like
well i will say barbie's now yes fierce
i actually have a few of these i have
this one 125 her super deep skin
yes gorgeous and i have her 132 in the
wheelchair
because fashionista lion they have
barbies in wheelchairs barbies with
prosthetics
yeah barbie that has um she's
african-american with no pigment in her
skin are you okay
she's she is she's interrupting you in
noises
oh yes wheelchair great i have yeah i
have her wheelchair great i love that
wheelchair great i don't really think my
dad's wheelchair
great but every time they come out with
something that's like you know
like she has a ramp it's a milestone
that there's a ramp
can i kind of say this is so interesting
because it me and whitney are both
fascinated you're giving us lessons
about
about womanhood because we obviously did
i didn't play with bobby's either yeah
we're not allowed to
my parents made me throw my bobbies out
why because they're too sexual and i was
like she could have microwaved it i was
new zealand got rid of barbies and
snakes
nope i was like well you're right we are
like scissoring with them like we are
maybe it's the way i was making my
barbies like have sex with each other
um so i was like okay cool have them
because sex is bad because i was
raised in that kind of well barbie's is
important because it's like the first
opportunity for
young girls to like be investigative
about sex and nudity
yeah otherwise they have no vocabulary
they can't talk about this stuff okay so
that's something that you wanted to go
on the internet
right i used to go to my friends houses
and they had barbies like a lot more
than me and they were always like a mess
and i'd like this is not correct
i was like we have to fix all of this
correct yeah they would just be naked
they wouldn't be in their house that
would be like what's happening
i was like you have all these options
and they're just laying naked in the
floor
with crazy hair i'm like what are you
doing yeah yeah this is abuse
so i'm getting like if they have like a
wheelchair or a prosthetic or like
there's one where she's african-american
has no pigment i always get them because
i'm like that's cool that's a milestone
so cool think about if you were a little
girl in a wheelchair and you saw this
come on
huge i always think about my dad huge
and if you are not in a wheelchair and
you're five years old
you had this toy and it's really
demystified what's a person in a
wheelchair and when you see so
you're not gonna go what's that crazy
you know i really like people in
wheelchairs come with their own ramps
right they just take them before they go
every year they do like careers
and uh astronaut was queer of the year a
few years ago it was a robotics and last
year was a judge
this year this year was uh this year uh
sorry 2020 the career of the year was
um presidential team it was a
president barbie who was black deep
black skin president
yes but never stand up comedian because
women aren't funny she's at a podium
and then she had a campaign manager so
somebody who's a voter and basically the
dolls came with like
the voting is the most important part of
the as like like a process
if you're a little black girl seeing the
president yeah
it's fierce i mean that's amazing that's
what's the idea that's amazing so
they've done
a a black president barbie but they
haven't done a female comedian or drag
queen barbie
they haven't done i mean paul did an
integrity barbie integrity toys um
what i like about the career ones though
is that it changes every year so it's
like
i just think i think a lot of people
have trauma with barbie i mean for me
originally it was like oh this was this
thing that represented my like secret
thing i wanted
that i knew not to ask for nobody told
me no but i knew like don't ask for that
no i
this is actually really important and i
know i know i tend to get super serious
on this podcast but it's like
to me i had such an adversarial
relationship with barb because like your
thighs can't touch i had so many fucking
eating disorders and so many like body
dysmorphic shit and it was like
there's so much there was so much weird
blame
on barbie about that shit um
that was miss uh uh
it was just like um blaming the wrong
thing
yes i think there's some scapegoating
going on because okay
let's say this many women a significant
number of women have eating disorders or
body dysmorphia but a significant number
of people have barbie
that doesn't mean that the barbie caused
this thing of course barbie's just a
popular toy
and america makes women feel like their
bodies aren't good enough these are both
true that doesn't mean they're related
but like now they make barbies of all
different shapes and sizes and colors i
will say
you have to think of what barbie allowed
little girls to imagine in the first
place that's it
if that had never been invented and
little girls now were only given babies
to play with babies yeah you can't have
a job you're a mom you're four and
you're a mom now
in the 80s i've never heard that point
before it's really it's so creepy i've
always thought it was a little boy it's
like for me like when i'm going to a
barbie all those
you know growing up i grew up people
weren't wearing clothes and stuff like
that that was the first time i saw like
fashion people weren't wearing clothes
it was the first yeah they were naked i
grew up in a nudist colony
yeah but they were like i never said i
was like barbie was like a fantasy that
people i didn't ever see i never saw
people like that in my hometown so i was
like whoa
yeah there's so many other things to me
it just represents possibilities
like when you're a woman like it's like
when you first start to grow
your shape it can be quite embarrassing
especially when you start
getting unwanted attention like it's
very like a lot of women can say
no such thing as unwanted attention it's
all wanted unwanted attention could be
one to could that be a bit unwanted
attention
i know that's your show amazing
does barbie does barbie still inspire
you as much now
as it did when you first started yes uh
obviously with the looks the hair the
costumes i mostly collect 60s to early
70s barbie
but to me barbie represents like america
really because every one of these dolls
comes in the same mold it's the same
machine same factories same plastic a
lot of times same skin color same shapes
the only thing that makes them different
is what they're dressed as so because
she's dressed as an astronaut she's an
astronaut because he is a surfer guy
he's a server
and in a it's dragged down yeah
he's a a guy i just uh
uh met on raya yeah this is everyone's
second boyfriend yeah of college
but like you are as what you're dressed
as and to me that's empowering you can
have anything you want because people
are just
faking it everyone's faking it mm-hmm
and you
are what you are dressed as really it's
a drag queen you dress as a rich famous
beautiful celebrity
and then people believe it because you
believe it it's the same psychology of
putting on a suit to make more money
mm-hmm you know
when you step out on stage to perform
it's like you're a pop star partially
because you dressed like it
now it's like happening and as you're
dressing you do actually
imagine what's the movie where she does
the reverse strip
it's so cool gi jane she's like or she's
she's dancing
yeah striptease but she puts clothes on
it's like the best strip
right yeah it makes me think of that
like just this
you know and i think that most people
when they get dressed up to go out it's
like you really are taking on
a another personality that you're
getting yeah that's so true the reason
you buy an outfit for a first date or a
job interview
it makes you feel like right we know you
obviously that you pull a lot of
inspiration from like barbies and
country music and dolly parton and
things like that where what what do what
do you pull inspiration from that people
would be
shocked by because those are kind of
like on the nose like we got that from
interviews and stuff like do you ever
get inspiration from something that
people are like really like
which is like for example let me give
you time to think because like from
for me like one of my biggest
inspirations is labyrinth and no one
would ever know that
the movie about the movie they do this
month
they found out they found out this month
the secret's out um
but like like david bowie is like very
influential to me marina abramovic
is very influential to me walt disney's
very influential to me like a lot of
people that i probably people would
think i'd like prior cards yeah
i mean we'll look for stand up like i
mean stand up has nothing to do with
fashion
west i mean maywest is my inspired by it
maywest is why i got into comedy
you know interesting i guess for me
um drag queens donuts i get more
inspired by people
yes people like regular like the
angelines of the world
or debbie harry like i don't really pay
attention to what the drag queens are
doing yeah pay attention to what people
who are vibrating somewhere and that
like that's not a person but that's not
a drag queen it's somewhere in the
middle
so yeah i heard you talk about michelle
branch the first time on an interview i
was like that's such i would never
thought that heading down michelle right
here
so like those are like really surprising
places different inspiration especially
from some that's so like
barbie yeah like my favorite my favorite
bands are like fountains of wayne or
like
whatever and so i don't think i listen
to traditionally like did not match with
the guy from weezer on raya
oh bummer which one rivers the one with
the sweater
rivers yeah there's cuomo so hot yeah
yeah not a fan so much of drag is like
having an encyclopedia of your own
knowledge right
yeah i i purposely pick not purposely
but
if i'm interested if i'm inspired by
something that i know other drag queens
don't look at
i lean in more because i want my pov to
be different
yeah do you have to be like your own dj
like the music you pick
like yeah like i i'll pick like i don't
really lip sync anymore but like
i don't ever write anything that i can't
see myself playing later like in a show
you know like i write it for this vessel
not for me to play
so it's like well how would trixie
deliver that and like is that too snarky
or like is that comedic enough
um i just try to make it like
i don't know something i would want to
do again like is this the last time i'm
doing this every time
every time we were talking about earlier
like every time you get on stage or
something
it's like pretend like this is the last
time you get to do this is this the last
time you're putting makeup on the last
song you're gonna do the last
make it the one yeah you're gonna do
that too because it really could be
and it also is like a trick you have to
do to
survive it's like how um uh
women after they give birth uh they
oxytocin floods their uh brains and they
feel
it feels really good because otherwise
women would never give birth again
because it's too painful yeah so it's
like we evolved
to have oxytocin flood the brain right
after
right after because no you feel i only
did it once and i was like when you hug
your baby
the pain is so toasty so sometimes when
they take the baby away straight away
the women don't get to get that flood of
oxytocin is that why they immediately
put the baby like on your chest why
would a woman ever have a kid
again after that nightmare and it helps
you forget it it's got it's going
to make you forget it that's right i've
read about that
you shake apparently you shake i
remember shaking a lot
and that's anti-trauma like when you
shake i thought it was parkinson's
yes they've had a baby
so they make you with michael j fox um
they make you
uh uh yeah it makes you forget
everything because no one would ever
have a child again
given yeah i had the one and i was like
and so
that's kind of an interesting way to
like anesthetize yourself but yeah
that's with stand up too it's like this
is the last time i'm ever going to do
this because if i envision myself doing
this forever i could never do it
it's too painful i'll try as hard it's
too painful i thought it would never go
away you probably wouldn't try as hard
yeah i guess for me too i also i think a
lot of drag queens start out with like
female impersonation and i really never
wanted to look i wanted to look like a
drag queen not a woman
yeah so i always wanted to look like a
thing that you could like pull a string
on the back
i didn't want to look real so i was
never interested in looking a certain
way like
passable up close you know like an
illusion i wanted people to be like
that's a man painted up crazy yeah like
that but you're not it's then you're not
copying anyone
right this is truly my favorite like one
of my i'm like a
i i can tell you my favorite jokes of
like people
like i have like my top ten favorite
jokes ever written by great joke writers
um i'm a dork about that but you sing
trying to get a cab saying i don't know
where it is but the oil
painting of jennifer coolidge is that an
oil painting of jennifer coolidge yeah
is such a fucking clean roast joke
that's such a kid it's true do you know
how many times the ubers have driven by
and
they cancel and keep going is that an
oil painting of jennifer cool
i mean it is i always say i could be her
stunt double have you met her
have i met her she was in two bro yes oh
right
i only met him one the best and she was
no twice and she was so nice she's a
drag queen
for sure she's the best she's a drag
queen yes correct oh
she's everything you want her to be and
more
yeah i love her is that an oil painting
like you i i think as people have to
understand how important
that is how smart that is how incisive
how specific
if someone had never seen me it's like
oh i get it it's just
it's a it's math like a lot of these
jokes are it's math
it's god it's so fucking funny um
i always say i also look like like in
the shows like the third tier the way
nosebleed seats are like oh my god this
dakota fanning
and then like up close they're like
that's janice from the muppets
because it's just lashes with a guitar
like you can see a hand like up my back
almost
the idea of you from far away is dakota
fanning oh
obviously because that's it for me you
can't tell me anything i know i look
crazy but like when i'm done getting
ready i'm like
is that sharon stone
[Laughter]
are we missing a sharon stone i just
believe it
but again drag you watch it to believe
it yeah because i believe it
like um suspension of disbelief
it's like i think drake has given so
many people confident it's like because
it makes you believe
even if you're not doing drag it makes
you believe your own story like
you get up and you put on a hoodie and
some
joggers you're like i am an athlete well
i was watching i mean we're gonna talk
about the crown
um uh but yeah i mean that's all dry
it's like
we're putting on a crown and then
everyone's like socially conditioned to
be like
oh my god you're right well it's just
like the queen is chosen
by god okay but we let's be
it's you know divine that's how i feel
about makeup too like
whatever whether or not you agree with
the society saying women wear makeup
if the tools are there and the world
responds to you a certain way you might
as well use them like
you might not agree with the fact that
the world thinks women should be makeup
all the time that's a whole other
conversation but
if putting mascara and concealer on does
get you the job and make people notice
you
you might as well do it absolutely i
love the new generation for yourself
yeah where's
the new generation wears makeup to be
something instead of to look pretty
and i love that like like like euphoria
did a really good job of like
those a lot of those people aren't
wearing makeup to look like sexy they're
wearing it they have like dots in their
eyebrows and like glitter all over their
cheek i mean they're wearing it because
they want to feel however that feels
yeah they want to and i love that the
new generation is like i'm wearing
makeup to become something
i'm wearing blush on my nose and winged
liner and i'm a boy and i draw a
mustache like
they're just doing whatever they want to
feel a certain way instead of wearing
makeup
the way that i think a lot of women
traditionally wore makeup which was to
be prettier yeah making me feel very old
well that's why barbie was so important
because at first she was shocking right
they're like we can't sell a toy with
nipples like
boobs are you crazy but in the early 60s
the second biggest fear was that my
daughter's too sexualized and too slutty
she's too desirable but the biggest fear
is what if she's not pretty enough
and can't get a man and can't get a meal
ticket so then that's actually a deeper
fear
right so then the parents were like well
if this is a toy that teaches my
daughter grooming
and how to be beautiful this is part of
training her to have a man
which is dark but it just or a dog
it just goes to show you that people are
people are always afraid of sex and
nudity period
it's the only thing everyone does but no
one talks about especially in america
yeah
that's why people are uncomfortable with
drag queens they think it's all about
sex
but here's the thing but my hot take on
that is like let my hot take on that is
like keep shit taboo because it just
makes us funnier
hello jim saying like i don't need all
these problems to be solved because we
get to be funny because you guys are
offended by shit so it's like cancel
culture like what you guys understand
you're making us stronger bitch like
it's like the more shit you're offended
by the more shit we
the more money we make yeah so keep
putting things off limits because that's
more material for us also when it's
taboo it can be more
fun too more attractive the more the
taboo the better you know so it's like i
don't it's it's when people complain
about this i'm like do you really want
this problem to be solved
yeah because then there's gonna be no
tension or conflict and that's where as
a performer you get your charge from is
knowing you're doing something
i'm not allowed to say this thing just
up to the line yeah
i always wanted to the one thing like my
favorite way to laugh is when like
school like you're not supposed to be
laughing
yeah it just makes you like oh my god
score laughing when you know it's
horrible and you shouldn't be laughing
it's catharsis and it's also like mo
people
are you know you know i think that this
whole thing has just been so
wildly patronizing to adults who are
like
we know you're joking we know you're not
racist
we know we know you're making fun of
racist people
we know you're making fun of this
stereotype we know that
you wouldn't say that if you actually
were homophobic
right you would never say that oh truly
homophobic person would never have said
that
you know what i'm saying like i think we
just are like in a
um i'm obsessed with how especially in
our business we are so
um classist and we just think that
anyone that doesn't live in la is like
so dumb that they don't get jokes
which is not true it could not be less
true it's roseanne 101 just because
rapport doesn't mean we're stupid
entertainment it's like you're rich
because a bunch of people not in l.a
also enjoy you
that's how you got it yeah i mean like
that's right
people don't watch anything right i know
the best shows ever
like the best shows are like alabama
where these people are like we've waited
all month for this
yes we're ready to go out yeah this is
the thing we have to do and we're ready
to laugh
they love it like la it's like i'll walk
around this corner and i'll have
something else to do
yeah like when i tour if i go to i don't
know this city brownsville texas
i'm like i'm not only gonna all these
people are gonna lose it every gay bar
in the city is gonna have
a crazy night making money you know like
you're creating an e
you're creating business for so many
businesses by coming to town you said
you're welcome economy
yeah i said thank you i said when i come
to that bar out of drag i better get a
drink
for free do you like that job i gave you
what i thought yeah
um i have so many more questions
i think at some point i have to release
you
well i don't want to it's only been what
30 minutes
but the car's left so we're going to
just back into the wild is that okay
we're going to release by you we mean
you're gonna sleep in that you live here
now you're gonna run and we're gonna see
how far you can get before the guns come
out
oh why did you do this podcast oh
why did i do it i just have always loved
you
and i love doing pods and then when i
realized oh this is a video one and i
was like
i thought about stacking a bunch of
stuff today and i was like i always
enjoy this more when i get in drag for
one thing i was like i'm just gonna get
and drag for you guys
like i don't know also let's just say
that if i was like
really really in drag all the time like
if i was touring these are exact kind of
things i don't get to do
if i'm gone all year yeah so anything
local that i've been asked to do i'm
like i'm gonna do it because normally
i'm not even here
is that a good answer what a dream the
other news is because i i stand
comedians and i so rarely get to
actually work with them because i'm
usually the comedian in the drag show
and i
you know we're on the drag q you know i
never get to hang out aren't we
disappointing though we're not that
funny in real life
irl but you guys should definitely tune
in
i mean like we're not like comedian it's
weird it's
it's interesting it's like podcasting is
like i'm so torn about it because it's
like
comics and we're together we just don't
want to embarrass ourselves by trying to
be funny in front of other comics
and this is how i know you're a real
comic is that i'm not trying to be funny
in front of you
yeah whenever i get asked to do like you
know john earlier something's like you
want to come to the satellite and do it
whenever a real comedian asks me to do a
real thing i just feel so included and
cool
yeah i know i i love comedians i know
you're a real comedian because i'm not
trying at all
no i know you're not real comedian
because can you buy that one i know
you're a real comedian
i'll write it down i know you're a royal
comedian because i phoned this because
i'm not trying i feel like
it's completely effortless i'm not doing
putting any effort in
i'm gonna say real comics when they get
together they're not on they don't do
bits they're just like
we get to be normal people for a second
and that's the energy i feel with that
i love me in this way i don't do bits
yeah it's weird like
i just feel like you and i can get
together and just be like ourselves
yes you know nothing like me and you can
get together
together we'll
we won't be ourselves me and natasha get
together and we're making the heels
we're playing every part well word for
word shot for shot remake of the hill
just me and natasha love it um i have
tons of more questions let's just do a
little run down of all the questions i
wrote out last night
let's do it what's the weirdest place
you've ever puked
oh i puked on a bus a public bus when i
was in college
public transit bus i used to date a
hipster and you know those people drink
yeah so like artsy people you are so
funny this question came about because
we were talking and i was like i'll puke
anywhere
i don't care i will i'll puke anything i
was picked
i was targets walmarts on myself the top
of runyon canyon the background people's
selfies puking all over myself
benton went for a hike when he first
came to la and puked
violently dramatically all over myself
all over everyone around me they were
taking selfies with the background
huge everywhere and then i stood up and
i was like i just walked on like
nobody else puke can make it up here
like it was like a psychopath hacked the
entire rest of the way covered in puke
you said ain't nobody doing it like me
look at it no one can do what i look at
the material look at the puke
look at the material new york
[Laughter]
uh i the weirdest place i've ever puked
is probably my mom's nursing home
in the parking lot wow that's dark
where is and you hadn't even gone in yet
you were just drinking brown paper bag
my mom didn't even live she's dead
i forgot to tell you she didn't live
there anymore she passed on yeah she
puked right in her casket crazy thing
and uh went to give her a kiss got
grossed out no i i
haven't you don't have any like
pregnancy surprise pukes or anything you
never puked
you are glad i haven't puked but i just
don't remember where i blacked it out
what kind of
i know i have an icon of natasha and
puke it's more oxytocin
puke one doesn't puke she said that part
is not written in this story
no i yeah i have no memory of where i
did
she said i'm not like you heather no i
just know that you can't eat
that food ever again yeah yeah
um and then we should like that
particular one yeah anyway i didn't oh
never stopped me i'll go right back i
couldn't eat carrots again
it's i will say like if i've drank to
the point of puking it does something
to that album yeah that like it ruined
um tequila
oh girl tequila it only takes puking up
tequila once it was my joke for a while
i was like
i like vodka but when i get drunk i like
to ask people to do me favors
i'll get drunk and we were to karaoke
bar one time and god is a woman came out
which is not a karaoke song just to be
very clear
beg that poor man at the karaoke i was
like please download this song
nobody wants to hear any song but this
song it's the only song of the night
to shut it down oh i sung i have a video
of me i'm singing this song
i mean you've never seen something so
bad in your life and i was up in
people's faces like
god is a woman like fully on table
like a psycho yep and it wasn't even
karaoke
sure it wasn't it was a tiki bar yeah it
was a burger king
it was a burger it was a cvs they said
man this is wendy's i said oh
um okay i have many other things that i
wrote down as so
excited about oh what's your favorite
movie
oh girl i know clueless
[Applause]
i think clueless is kind of a perfect
movie fashion the comedy but were they
not related in some way
they were step brother and step sister i
don't love it okay game of thrones but
it's
but i have some notes on that but it's
based on a shakespeare story you know
then siblings be marrying left and right
i don't care if you use your brother or
your dad if it's
him um bread you marry red yeah that's
your twin brother
correct you fuck rudd he sent me a video
once and it was like too much what was
it somebody who was working on a show
with him was like
hi and he was like hi trixie thank you
so much for loving me and i was like
because i always write these songs about
people i love in the world you know and
i wrote a song about jesse eisenberg and
he sent me a video saying thank you
once that's such a good song too
like paul rudd i would i would he knows
that i talk about him every other day
and entertainment
you're like how are you i'm like in love
with paul rudd how are you yes he's just
so hot to me
that is so funny i love hot nerdy jewish
guys
what if he wasn't in clueless still
still okay halloween got it so paul
reads your celebrity crush
oh yeah paul jesse eisenberg um
sometimes michael sarah depend on the
lighting
um brian reynolds is up there and um
danny glover and that's about it
i'm not picky what about you whitney
my celebrity crushes um
i don't who do i like we tried to do
this in an open one time we already had
sex with we tried to do this in an open
one time and you cut it because you kept
going
you have to be nice benton if we talk
about people that i'm attracted to
it you just can't do it and you just cut
the entire open
oh because you were like roasting you
didn't say anything we even started yet
never mind you can't do it
i will say one more thing about clueless
too i love that movie because it's
similar to true beverly hills where it
portrays a rich person as a good person
which never happens
rich women in movies are never good yeah
i love fantasies too
at least a silverstone i mean she
changed lives in the movie and brittany
murphy
stacey we don't talk about it but yeah
you know i just
love that it is yeah it is the music the
fashion she had 60 costume fittings for
that movie directed by a woman
i mean the looks of those movies all
right come on yeah timeless amazing
uh the aerosmith music videos with uh
alicia
when i met can i if i may when alicia
came to my when i was running my
my comedy central second comedy central
special i think she came to the
me running it because the director marty
corner
of my special directed those videos i
wanted i basically was like i want to
hire that
music video director special he's like
i came out of retirement i like begged
him to do thank god
two specials and so she came and watched
um
and i met her and that was probably the
most starstruck i've been actually
i was very like oh whoa because i just
pictured her like hanging off the thing
doing this
in that music video like that was she's
my kind of
she's up there she's in my atlantis
moore said like she's coming on the
podcast
i will um not be able to function
oh my gosh what's your favorite movie
atlantis is my probably dolly she like
really changed i mean i i got that album
the acoustic version of jack little pill
when i was 16 because that was the
10-year anniversary
and it just both of those versions of
chris won the real one just
amazing yeah songwriting just changed
songwriting
like amazing i should probably get off
these antibiotics
is an opening line of one of the songs
yes
i didn't mean to say that so loud we
liked it but then i go back
and i listened to i listened to it and
and tori and alanis i'm like these and i
was telling emily this i'm listening to
the songs now i'm like these bitches
were telling us
we didn't listen i mean what about
what's the song i want to be loved even
when i'm fuming
hmm atlantis good some about being good
i want to be good a lot of these ladies
um you listen to whole yes of course
does those whole albums
yeah yeah this woman is like predicting
the future yes that's right about fame
and
in the way people use women and it's
crazy it's just like listen they were
talking to us and we just like weren't
listening
so i'm like a big part of my homework
right now is going back and like
re-listening to
like tori amis like she like she was on
that me too shit like
way um but yeah elena said i would
probably
crumble remember she was at the event
that we were at oh yeah and i would
start crying
amazing she was i didn't even know i was
like you know when someone sings and you
find out you're a fan
like i just found myself going ah you
know it's the same when i saw a spice
girls concert i dash it don't oh my god
i'm not like i don't
like have all their pictures on my wall
but as soon as i heard them singing live
it was just like
it was over it was over yeah i met both
i met um
emma like baby once i met mlb too but
when i met um i had like a boost of pair
boots like these on and she told me my
boots had girl power
i was like wow she was like how are you
and i said
i spent a lot of my youth pretending to
be you and now a lot of my adulthood
i just like i love her i love
like i love tracy chapman and um
joni mitchell and people like that again
amazing songwriters
kylie simon like people like that
natasha what's your favorite movie
ah it's my worst question i don't know
why i hate that question
it is a weird it's a weird question but
it i like what happens to someone when
you ask it
i don't need to know the answer but i'm
probably going to say you mean gay
people like i'm probably going to say
zoolander
at work she's like beverly hills cop
yeah i love that
this is my favorite movie and straight
people like i don't have to really have
a favorite movie my boyfriend's a
filmmaker and so when i went on my first
date i knew he was a filmmaker and i was
like i know he's gonna ask about movies
so what are my favorite movies so i made
like a short list so i knew
you're like you're just showing up with
like i worked with a guy that used to
carry a list
in his billfold of his 500 favorite
movies
what that is that is carried around with
him yellow paper
500. i i hate the idea of someone asking
him not knowing what they're getting
into
i do just like what happens to people's
brains when you ask them their favorite
movie they get angry and they feel
attacked oh i know immediately oh
really because craft people feel
attacked
because you're judging them right
because they're going like oh like it's
it's so
intimate it's so they're afraid of what
the room thinks if they pick something
too
palatable do they have to be smart it
has to be esoteric
it has to be smart that's like when
you're like what's your favorite
christmas movie and someone's like die
hard i'm like
you need to die okay i get you think
that's a christmas movie that's not what
i asked
say oh never heard that before bitch
exact
uh it's actually diehard um it's so much
more interesting just answer the
question
that should be but yeah it's just like
overthink everything like that
yeah no but i think it's just more about
like a uh it's an interesting how
insecure i get when someone asks me that
question and i'm just i get sweaty
i know i get like panicky yeah i have to
stretch first before i know i need a
question about my own like taste okay i
love you
um we're not gonna promote your makeup
because it's already selling too well so
don't buy trixie's makeup yes if you'd
like to see some fabulous products we
have trixiecosmetics.com
don't buy them another sell out this
week stop
this is my like like you're making a
for people that's honest that is one of
the best comments i've ever gotten
because i wanted it to feel like a polly
pocket or a party like
you know what if he also feels like to
me um trapper keepers
speaking of proper keepers yes totally
speaking of polly pocket
another great quote from whitney
remember this shit
we said we're all talking about polly
pockets and when he goes who is polly
i know like the toy talking she goes i
had a bad childhood and then just left
the room with all that i don't know i
said can we pivot this back to this
problem
is there anything with me to fit in that
i was i caught on fire and i haven't
seen that before on makeup
what i literally love everything i love
you well i
tell you all all nice makeup comes in
black plain packaging and all fun makeup
is not good formulas so our mission was
like can we make pro formulas in like
claire's packaging
didn't you use a toy designer to make
this yeah the person who designs he's um
full time his full-time job is making
toys for a big toy company love that
everybody we work with has
they have toys the buffy glitter these
are glitters
these are different glitters uh these
are some of our glosses lipsticks blush
palettes
um we just had a lipstick launch a few
days ago red skier sold out again we
have an
this this comes out in a few weeks right
yeah few weeks we have a
palette our first eye palette coming out
in february it's a blue eye palette it's
incredible
it's slutty slutty blues and the
palette's called daytime realness
this buffy glitter so my favorite tv
show yeah
i was like i remember this when this was
i was like
i know um we have stuff coming out this
year literally multiple launches a month
through the whole year because we've
grown so much
last year in covet i mean i don't know
what whores were doing they weren't at
work
they were buying makeup these bitches
were home always saying making youtube
videos
kind of recession or money thing
entertainment and and cosmetics never
we hired all year like we we needed
people we've grown so much we're moving
into a new office new warehouse doubling
our size it's crazy
that's amazing this buffy glitter
is little crosses and hearts yeah it's
fun but what stop it with not getting
like how do you get glitter i know
that's probably just like the basic just
like the way you apply it like ours
comes with a sifter
that's how you do it ours comes with a
sifter
so or you can pull the sifter out i
don't use a sifter um
use a base so like i use lash glue
usually and then press it into it
i like putting glitter on my eyebrows we
our glitters are limited we usually put
them out with color collections and then
like limited editions lady gaga has a
glitter brow gel and then this just came
out mod about you i'm really proud of it
i love it it's fun orange
is it orange oh wait who is the person i
love
who does it who's the designer woman's
name trapper keeper
oh um lisa frank lisa frank yes obsessed
aretha franklin everything and then we
did their queen size pans because i like
when blushes are like a hubcap size give
me like
give me a big picture i need a but i
also like i got a big head
i'm also obsessed with and i want i will
do this eventually i want to see your
makeup
and see the way your lipsticks are
shaped
because i'm obsessed with the way when
uh when a woman has used a lipstick a
lot
people do some weird stuff the shape of
the lipstick is flat
yeah isn't it interesting my lipsticks
are flat after i've used them a lot you
know some of them are like some people
like yes that is so gross to me
so weird it's like a towel it's like a
little witch is put on your legs i knew
one girl she
she twisted up all the way and then she
would do both flips at once and then
eventually it would just break off in
the middle
and i'm like that is so sick yeah oh
wait like like
irish springs soap i really like this
one this is like a translucent pink
really 80s
heaven
um i love neutrals but i also i mean i
love really brights too
yeah it's fun making makeup i i when i
used to work in the makeup stores i
always used to like something would come
out and i would be like
here's what i would have done
differently this is the wrong name this
should have been right it smells weird
and it's fun to be able to just have a
saying to do it now it's a lot of work
though
to be honest if i don't know as much
work as it is i'm not saying it would
have started but like
it took a long time to get the rhythm
yeah you have to make past how long does
this take
how long does this take oh probably a
year one year five months a year one
year
huh who would have found not to mention
like if you want to make lip glosses
great there's all this work to at first
even come up with this component this
tube this shape
and then you're talking about the
formulas the colors the shades the scent
what's the price point
what countries can you do it legally and
how do you get through those holes of
how to do it
shipping it to store shipping to people
it's just there's so much to it but we
have a very talented team it's like all
women
yeah do you have like a signature thing
like one thing that
is like your best a lot of brands do
have like a i'm really proud of actually
really like puff this nude gloss but do
you have stacy's mom is that here
uh i think it's that one oh this is
stacy's mom i love stacy's mom this like
vegan so good so
good it's like a vegan hot pink it's um
wait and then i would do i'm so you do
have perfect lips
you said should i put this on well yeah
why not
i it's fun because it's pink but it's
kind of muted it's it's not neon
yeah it's kind of purple based almost
yeah and it's vegan yeah
i love wild and i had to name it after
stacey's mom because i love fountains of
wayne that band
for my next special do i do a full
trixie look
i mean tricks these little stuff but not
that's not these lashes i'll borrow
these lines
copyright no i mean like your makeup
she'll be in this look with the guitar
and gogo boots i'll be like hmm
she's looking very beautiful yeah not
familiar
is you asking how to come on the ride
with you i'll just go out for it you can
be a makeup artist i'll have your jokes
written down
oh yes
she's done that before where she got
someone to read her jokes that's right
it was really funny
i'm trying to figure out a way to get
someone to replace me yeah yeah i had
the robot that i'm trying to get you are
the meme of that girl sitting in the
back seat like
well thank you for i mean this has been
such a dream and what a dream i end
these very awkwardly
um and uh anything else we want to say
please follow me everywhere at trixie
mattel you can listen to my music watch
my youtube channel you can watch my
netflix show you can just watch me
anywhere i just love you
insult people what content dream you are
what a dream
i've learned so much my heart is so full
i feel very healed
i am like personally like so
like thrilled and inspired to see
someone who came from like a small town
who had like a very similar like
experience like doing such cool things i
think that's like if i would have saw
this
um i mean we're very close in age but if
i would have saw this like as a child i
would have been like
i could do fucking anything yeah totally
my dream i want to go do a special in my
hometown someday yes please
i feel like 500 people but i want to get
like rent the bowling alley do it the
locals
do it i'm doing that at west virginia i
feel like so much of and maybe
this was so much of like being like a
gay boy growing up is you have to
constantly look for women and just
figure out how to find yourself within
what they're doing
like you have to find female comedians
be like well that's similar to me or
watch movies like clearly something like
i relate to this because like you're
having to figure out where you fit in
and like having now having like like
even this podcast
or like drag race and all this stuff and
being able to see someone like that but
that is so similar to my story would be
like
so life-changing for kids i think yeah
or adults not even just kids
like grown-ups are still trying to
figure that out yeah so that's really
cool good for you
still finding yourself in a woman and
you're absolutely beautiful and just
your energy
you have such a great energy you know i
feel like people are like your energy is
around here like i can feel you
it is it does feel wonderful to be in
your presence thank you well you're very
kind i feel like this makeup expired
about six hours ago
it's makeup does go bad just say i'm
glad when i step outside it's gonna be
dark out
that driver would have just hit it oh
god it's jennifer it's just
love you it's no it's it's um
it's jennifer coolidge is an oil
painting
yeah not even the woman the martian
don't write elephants i love you guys
[Music]
[Applause]